[Musique]
Maurice Gourdeau Montagne. Bonsoir.
Bonsoir. Nous vous recevons pour une
chaîne internet qui s'appelle Syerview.
Nous sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous
pouvez vous présenter succintement ?
Voilà, je m'appelle Maurice Gourde
Monontagne, j'ai 71 ans, j'ai été
diplomate pendant 41 ans. J'ai été à la
fois dans des ambassades à l'étranger, à
peu près la moitié de ma vie. Et puis
sinon la l'autre moitié à Paris euh j'ai
été porte-parole du Kedoret, j'ai été en
cabinet euh auprès du premier ministre
comme de cabinet, c'était monsieur Jupé,
j'ai été auprès du président Chirac
comme conseiller diplomatique et cherpa
du G7 G8. Voilà. Donc c'est une vie bien
remplie et j'ai eu la chance pendant 25
ans sur ces sur ces 40 ans de d'être
proche, je dirais de la manière dont les
choses se décidaient ou ne se décidaient
pas.
Maurice,
avec toute cette expérience,
la diplomatie française, quel regard tu
portes dessus à l'heure actuelle ?
On est dans un moment
tout à fait particulier. On est dans un
moment de bouleversement absolu de tous
les points de repère. Et je suis né sous
la guerre froide. Euh, je suis rentré au
CADOC en 1978
à 25 ans. Euh, à l'époque, il était
impensable d'imaginer la chute euh de
l'Union soviétique, que le mur de Berlin
allait tomber. Euh impossible d'imaginer
ce qui allait se passer après. Alors, il
faut essayer de prendre des points de
repère. Euh, j'ai souvent un point de
repère qui est lié à au moment où je
suis rentré au quador en 1979.
C'est une année charnière où on a d'une
part
l'arrivée de Rean comme président des
États-Unis, de Satcher comme premier
ministre de Grande-Bretagne et tous les
deux sont des adeptes de
l'ultralibéralisme et donc de la
libération des flux financiers partout.
On fait sauter les barrières, on met en
œuvre les théories de Milton Friedman
finalement et euh ça permet à l'argent
de circuler et ça va permettre à un
certain nombre de pays de sortir de la
pauvreté. Première chose, 1979.
Deuxièmement, en 1979, très important
aussi, c'est euh l'arrivée des
soviétiques en Afghanistan. Et là, je me
rappelle, j'étais de permanence cette
nuit-là au Cadors c'était un 25
décembre. Et on reçoit une dépêche,
c'était comme ça à l'époque, une dépêche
AFP.
Les soviétiques sont entrés en
Afghanistan. On vérifie avec notre
ambassade, les soviétiques sont entrés
en Afghanistan. Babrak Karmal, c'était
le nom du du dirigeant afghan de
l'époque, a été renversé. Et donc, les
soviétiques sont là. Et nous nous
disons, on fait toutes les
vérifications, on en parle avec les
partenaires. Moi, j'étais j'étais un
jeune, j'étais de permanence dans la
petite chambre qu'on avait au Quédoret.
GTA Junior, mais j'écoute un peu ce qui
se passe parce que quand on est là, le
jour où il y a un 25 décembre évidemment
ou un 26 décembre, il y a pas grand
monde donc les chefs arrivent, parlent
entre eux et moi j'étais dans un coin,
j'écoutais ce qui se passait et la
théorie qui sort va être l'expansion du
communisme qui va se poursuivre sur la
planète.
Et là, il s'est avéré que c'était pas
ça. C'était le début de la fin parce que
et ça je on va on va voir pourquoi. 1979
encore, Dengoping arrive comme dirigeant
de la Chine. C'est la fin de la
révolution culturelle.
il prend le pouvoir et ça va être le
début d'une Chine que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui. Et puis 1979, c'est
l'arrivée de l'Atola Comé en Iran qui va
arriver avec cette révolution islamique
prosélite destinée à s pendre partout et
qui va générer un début de de révolution
terroriste dans l'ensemble de la région.
Donc voilà, quatre événements qui sont à
mon avis des moments tournants d'un
cycle qui est en train aujourd'hui de
s'achever parce que entre-temps,
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ? Entre-temps,
on a eu Rean et Satcher. Rean, ça a été
l'emballement
de la machine américaine dans ce qu'on
appelait la course aux étoiles qui était
une course aux armements. Et l'Union
Soviétique n'a pas pu tenir la distance.
Et donc l'Union Soviétique est tombée
à force de ne pas pouvoir, je dirais
tenir le choc. Elle n'a pas pu se
moderniser. Le système était totalement
nécosé. s'est effondré et on a eu la
chute du n soviétique en 1991
90-91 après la chute du mur et donc un
nouveau monde qui s'est constitué. La
Chine d'iaoping, on voit la Chine qui
s'ouvre, c'était la réforme et
l'ouverture. La Chine devient une grande
puissance et aujourd'hui la deuxième
puissance mondiale et ça bouleverse
l'ensemble des équilibres de la planète.
L'Iran, on est au terme d'un d'un
processus aujourd'hui. Est-ce que le
régime iranien tel qu'il existe va
survivre
à la recherche d'un nouveau souffle ? il
est épuisé militairement,
socialement, économiquement.
Donc si on met tout ça bout à bout, on
se rend compte que finalement l'histoire
évolue par cycle. Et donc aujourd'hui la
diplomatie, qu'est-ce qu'elle peut faire
? C'est c'est ta question. Qu'est-ce que
fait la diplomatie ? Ben, il faut
essayer de s'y retrouver. Il faut
essayer de retrouver des points de
repère. Il faut essayer de voir comment
nous allons nous placer dans un monde
qui est en train de se transformer.
Parce que à mon avis, la chose la plus
fondamentale qui s'est passée, c'est
finalement les conséquences de ce qui a
été de de cette circulation massive de
l'argent à la surface du globe qui a
permis des investissements, qui a permis
à des pays de sortir de la pauvreté et
qui a permis l'émergence d'un certain
nombre de pays et donc l'émergence d'un
monde multipolaire avec l'Inde, avec la
Chine, avec le Brésil, avec l'Indonésie,
avec l'Iran, avec la Turquie. des pays
qui ont quelquefois des rêves d'empire,
des pays qui ont des clients, des pays
qui cherchent, je dirais, à asseoir leur
influence et qui sont devenus des
puissances politiques, des puissances
économiques, militaires, souvent
technologiques, c'est le cas d'un
certain nombre d'entre elles. Et donc
comment est-ce qu'on s'organise et
comment nous nous trouvons notre place ?
Et donc pour
pour je dirais pour conclure cette
description qui mérite d'être
approfondie,
moi je suis un adepte d'un d'un auteur
qui s'appelle Kishor Mabouani. Quichor
Mabouani est un diplomate singapourien
euh qui a été président de l'Assemblé
générale des Nations- Unies et qui a
écrit un certain nombre de livres sur
l'évolution du monde et il a une phrase
qui résume à mon avis tout. La
parenthèse
de domination de l'Occident qui a duré
400 ans est en train de se refermer.
Donc les 400 ans, c'est quoi ? C'est la
période depuis le début de la
colonisation, depuis l'expansion
coloniale, la conquête de l'Amérique et
jusqu'à aujourd'hui, c'estes 4 ou 500
ans, disons, elle est en train de se
refermer. Elle n'est pas refermée.
L'Occident a encore des choses à dire.
Il a imprimé sa sa marque sur l'ensemble
de la planète. Mais comment est-ce que
l'Occident se se retrouve dans cet
ensemble où il y a d'autres puissances,
d'autres pouvoirs et comment ce qu'on
s'organise ? Donc que fait la diplomatie
? Ben la diplomatie, elle a tout à fait.
Il faut reprendre les choses à zéro. Il
faut réorganiser le monde et les
systèmes mis en place jusqu'à présent ne
fonctionnent pas. Donc il faut
réinventer.
C'est ta réponse. C'est mon début de
réponse.
Un truc qui m'a fait marrer, c'est
une ambassade, c'est c'est informé par
la FP.
Alors, c'était pas l'ambassade, j'étais
de permanence au qu d'ors pire. Non, on
est informé bah on est informé par la
FP, on est informé par des télégrammes
de l'ambassade
en question. On avait une ambassade à
Kaboule qui nous a aussi informé. Donc,
on a on a comparé, je ne sais pas si la
dépêche de la FP est arrivée en même
temps que le télégramme de l'ambassade,
mais il est évident que en général la FP
corrobor des choses qu'on sait à
l'avance. quelquefois on en sait plus.
Notre ambassadeur à Kabou que j'ai
beaucoup fréquenté par la suite parce
qu'il a été expulsé donc il fallait
qu'il soit quelque part et j'ai partagé
le même bureau pendant 3 ans euh jusqu'à
ce qu'il soit en retraite. Euh il avait
vécu l'arrivée des soviétiques, il avait
vécu l'expulsion de l'administration
afghan de l'époque et cetera. Et ça, il
a écrit beaucoup de choses. On savait ce
qu'il écrivait, on savaitce qui se
passait. Ça, la FP ne le racontait pas.
Mais l'AFP joue un rôle absolument
fondamental et je pense que l'AFP reste
pour la France un atout euh exceptionnel
avec les autres grandes agences qui ont
été retires ces à ce châtié de presse.
C'est quoi son surnom en Afrique à la FP
? Vas-y. Agence France Propage.
Je pense que c'est inexa. Je pense que
c'est inexat de dire que comme ça que
les africains perçoivent. On peut le
dire comme ça mais on peut dire que
reter s'est fait de la propagande pour
les Britanniques, que là sa châté de
presse pour les Américains. Euh les
agences l'agence iranienne, l'agence
russe, l'agence indienne et cetera,
l'agence chinoise, chinoi.
Je pense que s'agissant de la
déontologie de la presse, les agences en
général font de l'information et pour
moi qui ai eu la chance de fréquenter
beaucoup de journalistes et de croiser
mon regard avec le regard des
journalistes qui n'est pas exactement la
même que nôtre, nous nous avons un nous
essayons d'avoir un regard qui amène à
des options que nous prenons pour une
action ou pour une décision
particulière. Le journaliste, il informe
en général la plume d'un journaliste
passé par la FP, ça se remarque tout de
suite. Un article d'un journaliste qui a
été agencié, ça se remarque tout de
suite. Il y a une précision dans le le
sujet, la manière de capter l'événement
qui est tout à fait exceptionnel. Donc
je ne pense pas qu'il y ait que le
journaliste qui est agencier perde, je
dirais, son regard critique parce qu'il
est agencier.
Comment tu perçois
ce qui se passe avec la guerre avec les
Russes et les Ukrainiens ?
Tu commences à partir de 2008
jusqu'à aujourd'hui.
Écoute, c'est la guerre cette guerre
avec les les entre la Russie et
l'Ukraine, cette agression de la Russie
en Ukraine, bon sait qu'elle remonte à à
février 2022,
c'est pas sorti par hasard et je pense
qu'il y a eu un certain nombre de
signaux qui remontent finalement à la
chute de l'Union Soviétique. J'étais à
bonne à l'époque et donc capital de
République fédérale d'Allemagne. Bon au
premier plan, c'était l'époque où on a
négocié les accords qu'on a appelé 4 +
2, les quatre puissances occupantes de
Berlin et puis les deux Allemagnes qu'on
a fixé la frontière Nice. On a négocié
des traités, les Allemands négocié des
traités avec la avec la Russie, ce qui
était devenu la Russie. Euh il y a eu
une série de d'accords et il y a eu, je
dirais, un monde à reconstruire. Ce qui
m'a frappé à l'époque, c'est que on a
perdu de vue l'idée que la sécurité des
États est pour eux la chose la plus
fondamentale. La sécurité est pour nous
une chose fondamentale aussi. Quand on
est quand on est propriétaire d'un
appartement et qu'on a des voisins
turbulents euh et bien il y a un code de
copropriété. Si on se met d'accord sur
un certain nombre de règles, si le type
met ses ordures sur votre paillasson,
s'il cherche à défoncer votre porte,
vous essayez, on essaie de se préparer,
on prend des on prend des mesures. En
l'occurrence, quelle était la priorité
en 1990 91 ? C'était de reconstruire les
pays d'Europe centrale orientale sur le
plan économique car on s'aperçut que
c'était un effondrement général. Et
c'était la Russie. la Russie qui était
dans un chaos énorme. On se rappelle
Jeffreza Ax en train d'orienter les
vouchers pour les Russes, les oligarques
qui ont commencé à mettre la main sur
l'appareil de production russe. Bref,
pendant ce temps-là ne s'occupa pas de
sécurité. Or, pourtant, la guerre froide
avait permis grâce à ce qu'on a appelé
les négociations sur la coopération et
la sécurité en Europe avec les accords
d'elsinki de 1975 de mettre en place
tout un dispositif d'accord de contrôle
des armements. On se regardait en chien
de faillance mais on était organisé, il
y avait des mesures de confiance, des
mesures de surveillance et c'est comme
ça qu'on a eu des accords qui se sont
mis en place au fur et à mesure jusque
dans les au début des années jusqu'à la
fin des années 90 sur les forces
conventionnelles en Europe, sur les
forces nucléaires intermédiaires. Il y a
eu les accords Start, il y a eu les
accords anti missile balistique, fameux
accords ABM. On avait tout un arsenal
d'accord qui permettait de garder
l'équilibre entre les deux blocs qui
étaient les États-Unis comme patron du
bloc occidental et puis l'Union
soviétique à parité à quasi parité de
force nucléaires.
Donc on surveillait tout ça. La période
qui a suivi 1990 est une période où on a
laissé tomber cette dimension des
choses, à part un seul élément qui était
qu'est-ce qu'on fait de l'OTAN et on a
décidé qu'on allait conserver l'OTAN.
Personnellement, je faisais partie des
gens qui se posaient des questions sur
l'OTAN. Est-ce que c'était nécessaire de
garder l'OTAN qui était destiné à
contenir les forces du pact de Varsovie
qui était on se rappelle, on regardait
toujours la carte en voyant le saillant
de l'Alsace et la distance qu'il y avait
jusqu'à Pilsen qui était le saillant de
la Tchegoslovaquie, il y avait 150 km.
On disait combien de temps les
soviétiques mettront-ils pour arriver
débouler à Strasbourg avec leurs chars ?
C'était ça la question qu'on se posait.
Bon, on avait donc cette situation euh
où qu'est-ce qu'on fait de l'OTAN ? on a
décidé de maintenir le temps. Est-ce que
la promesse a été faite l'Union
soviétique de ne pas étendre le temps ?
Il y a des textes notamment des des
rapports entre les directeurs politiques
de l'époque, c'est-à-dire l'américain,
l'anglais, le français et l'allemand qui
rapporte que il on nétendra pas le temps
au-delà de l'elve. C'est pas ça a pas
été uniquement formulé d'une façon
verbale. Alors ça c'est ça a été formulé
mais ça c'est dans un compte-rendu.
Ensuite, il y a eu les ce qu'on dit les
Russes et notamment Gorbatchov et
le haut les hauts dirigeants russes
qu'il y avait eu des promesses de James
Baker qui était secrétaire d'État
américain qu'il n'y aurait pas pas un
pouce d'utant supplémentaire vers l'est.
Euh Duma dans ses mémoires dit la même
chose. Baker le dit lui-même.
C'était oral. Y a-t-il eu un engagement
formel ? Sans doute pas. Mais en
l'occurrence, la question n'était pas
là. La question c'était comment est-ce
qu'on reconstruit l'économie de ces pays
qui étaient en train de s'effondrer ? Le
temps a passé. Et le temps a passé et
il y a une phrase de Poutine qui dit qui
a dit un jour la plus grande catastrophe
qui nous soit arrivée c'était
l'effondrement de l'Union soviétique. On
a affaire à une génération de dirigeants
russes qui aujourd'hui ont tous été
encore formés en Union soviétique, qui
ont vécu dans cette grande union
soviétique qui était l'héritière de
l'Empire Deszard et qui était
l'héritière aussi enfin qui avait gagné
1945 qui avait donc annexé par exemple
les Républiques Balt qui avait créé le
pact de Varsovie qui s'était avancé
jusqu'à Berlin puisque l'Allemagne était
coupée en deux
et que Berlin était qui était en
Allemagne de l'Est un espèce d'il en
Allemagne de l'Est était coupé en quatre
avec une zone pour chaque chaque chaque
puissance occupante.
On a cette situation et donc avec des
tunnels des deux côtés d'ailleurs.
Comment ? Avec des tunnels des deux
côtés. Avec des tunnels des deux côtés
avec bref une situation dans laquelle je
répète on ne s'occupait que de
reconstruire l'économie sans s'occuper
des questions de sécurité et avec une
une néanmoins chez certains une
inquiétude sur ce qui pouvait se passer.
Et quelqu'un comme Chiraak que j'ai
servi pendant 5 ans euh se rendait bien
compte pour fréquenter Poutine
énormément avec lequel il avait réussi à
créer une certaine relation de confiance
puisque les Russes, rappelons-le,
étaient avec nous contre la guerre en
Irak par exemple, qu'on avait réussi
dans le cadre européen à créer ce qu'on
appelait les espaces de coopération.
Bref, on essayait d'amadouer les Russes,
de les habituer, je dirais, à une
coopération avec l'Ouest. Il y avait une
certaine espérance de la part des
Russes. Rappelons-nous qu'après le 11
septembre 2001, la le premier dirigeant
qui a appelé le président américain
après le bon les les tours jumelles,
c'était Poutine en proposant son aide.
Donc il y avait Est-ce que tu as vu le
cadeau des Russes aux États-Unis pour
commémorer le le les attentats du 11
septembre ? Non, je l'ai pas vu. Un
modèle d'architecture avec une goutte
magnifique. Ah oui oui oui. Donc il y a
eu une sensibilité à cette époque-là et
néanmoins, on sentait une certaine
acryonie de la part des Russes qui
étaient al utilisé le mot humilié mais
le sentiment peut-être qu'on ne prenait
pas assez en compte leur leurs
préoccupations. À partir de 1997, l'OTAN
avait avancé dans un certain nombre de
pays. La France était d'accord avec
cette avancée parce que en fait les pays
qui avaient été sous la coupe du pact de
Varsovie dominés par les soviétiques,
ils avaient toute raison de vouloir se
protéger parce qu'on ne sait jamais. Les
pays baltes qui sont entrés en 2004, les
pays baltes, ils avaient été occupés par
les soviétiques et d'être devenus des
Républiques socialistes soviétiques.
Donc il y avait tout cela. Puis il y
avait la question ukrainienne qui
commençait à pointre et Chirak avait
senti ça et
m'avait envoyé fin 2006 avec un collègue
de l'Élysée, Laurent Billy en
l'occurrence qui est maintenant
ambassadeur à Washington après avoir été
en Chine pour faire une proposition aux
Russes et la proposition était la
suivante que nous avions transmise à à
Serge Protco qui était le conseiller
diplomatique du président Poutine qui
était la suivante.
Il y a un problème avec l'Ukraine,
il faut garantir la sécurité de
l'Ukraine.
On avait le mémorandum de Budapest
depuis 1994 qui était en fait créé qui
avait été créé au moment où il y avait
eu le transfert des armes nucléaires de
l'Ukraine vers la Russie et il y avait
une garantie américano anglo-russe sur
l'Ukraine. Mais Shirac sentait que tout
ça n'était pas très fort. Il fallait
donc parler et Shira avait fait la
proposition qui était écoutez pourquoi
ne pas avoir une protection croisée de
l'Ukraine ? l'OTAN protégerait d'un côté
la Russie de l'autre et ce serait le
conseil autant Russie qui serait le
gestionnaire de cette protection croisé
sur l'Ukraine.
Là où c'était intéressant, c'est que
l'interlocuteur russe à qui j'avais
transmis mon mémorandum, une espèce de
de draft, un projet mais qui était
informel,
lit ce que j'avais écrit et ce que nous
avions écrit et me dit "Mais ça c'est
très intéressant, ça nous réglerait le
problème de Sbastopol."
Et là, on comprend tout de suite que
l'Ukraine pour les Russes c'est la
Crimée. Et Sévastopol, on le sait, avait
un régime particulier qui était un
régime de location à bail en Ukraine
puisque la Crimée était ukrainienne
depuis 1954 quand CR chef l'avait
transmise avait transmise la la
l'Ukraine de la Russie à avait transmis
la Crimée de la Russie à l'Ukraine,
le port de Sébastopol était loué à bail.
Or pour les Russes comme la l'OTAN
continuait à avancer, imaginez que
l'Ukraine rentre dans l'OTAN et que le
port de Sébastopol soit encerclé par
l'OTAN, c'était quelque chose de
totalement inconcevable.
Alors Chirak avait eu cette idée mais
évidemment on était en 2006, fin 2006,
il m'avait dit aller voir les Allemands
et aller voir les Américains après. Donc
mon collègue russe me dit est-ce que tu
en as parlé aux Américains ? Je dis non
mais je vais d'abord voir les Allemands
et puis ensuite les Américains me dit
moi ça nous intéresse, il faut qu'on en
reparle. J'ai donc été voir les
Allemands un vieux collègue qui
s'appelait Christophe qui a été
président de la conférence de Munich
plus tard qui a été pendant une
quinzaine d'années le conseiller de
madame Merkel. Je lui montre le le cette
idée, je lui explique, il me dit "C'est
très compliqué, il faut en as-tu parlé
aux Américains
Bon, réflexe naturel de nos amis
allemands. Donc je vais voir
Conisa R qui à l'époque était scrataire
d'état avec qui j'avais quelques
relations à l'époque où elle était
conseillée pour la sécurité à l'époque
de la guerre en Irak même si nous étions
pas du tout du même avis mais on on
avait réussi à établir une relation
assez confiante. On pouvait se dire
beaucoup de choses. C'était à l'époque
où on avait encore du renseignement de
qualité. On a encore du renseignement de
qualité. On pouvait parler, on pouvait
on pouvait évoquer avec des gens avec
qui on était pas d'accord toutes sortes
de sujets. Et je lui parle de ce projet
et là elle se met à rigoler. Elle me dit
"Les français, "Écoutez, ça ça commence
à bien faire. Vous avez essayé
d'empêcher la première vague d'adhésion
des pays de l'Europe centrale et
orientale à l'OTAN.
Vous n'allez pas empêcher la deuxième
vague. Ce jour-là, fin 2006, j'ai
compris que et nous avons compris quand
j'ai rapporté tout ça au président de la
République, monsieur Chirac, on a
compris que l'Ukraine était l'étape
suivante dans l'esprit des Américains.
2007, on a eu le discours de Poutine à
la conférence de Munich dans laquelle il
pouche un coup de gueule et il menace.
Et Jacqu n'était plus là, c'était
président Sarkozi qui était là. 2008 qu'
sommet de Bucarest de l'OTAN et sommet
de Bucarest la décision est prise
d'avoir une espèce de feuille de route
pour l'adhésion de l'Ukraine et de la
Géorgie à l'OTAN. À la demande de la
France et de la de l'Allemagne et bien
la décision est suspendue mais elle
reste comme une épée de Damoclè et à
partir de ce moment-là les Russes
deviennent comme fous perdent la tête.
Et c'est l'époque où on commence à ne
plus mettre en œuvre ce qui avait été
décidé dans le cadre entre la Russie et
l'Union européenne qui était les fameux
espaces de coopération, espace de
coopération économique, espace de
coopération scientifique et cetera. Tout
ça est interrompu et puis on aboutit à
2014. Et 2014, c'est l'affaire du
Maidan. Alors, les Russes avaient déjà
observé la fameuse révolution orange de
2004 euh avec suspicion parce que il y a
en Ukraine, quand on regarde l'Ukraine
et quand on regarde les élections en
Ukraine, si on regarde une carte
électorale, ce qu'on ne fait jamais
assez, il y a deux parties. Il y a le
Nieep au milieu, à l'ouest, il y a des
gens qui votent d'une certaine manière
et à l'est qui votent d'une autre
manière. Les interlocuteurs ukrainiens
que j'ai eu personnellement, les
conseillers diplomatiques, selon les
gouvernements au pouvoir étaient soit
pour l'adhésion à l'OTAN, soit contre
l'adhésion à l'OTAN. Il y a deux
sensibilités en Ukraine. C'est un pays
qui s'est construit aux marches de de la
Russie, aux marches de l'Empire
austro-hongrois. Euh le LVOF, c'était
Lemberg. Euh bref, c'est un pays qui a
aussi c'est construit au marge de la
Pologne. C'est un pays qui est construit
sur des sur des traditions culturelles,
des traditions politique différentes. Si
on lit le livre de Benoît Méchin euh sur
l'Ukraine que je recommande vivement,
euh on voit tout ça. Il y a une identité
ukrainienne mais elle est variée, elle
est diverse. Et donc comment traiter
cette affaire ? Et donc les Russes sont
devenus extrêmement nerveux et après ça
on est entré donc on a eu l'annexion de
la Crimée, on a eu l'entrée des Russes à
Louansk et enfin dans le dans le Donbas
Louansk et Donet et puis 2022 les choses
sont montées en puissance et
et là tu connais les Russes un peu ? Je
connais qui ? Les Russes. Ah oui, je
connais les Russes un peu. Oui. Mais tu
les connais comment ? Je les connais
pour les avoir beaucoup fréquenté à
l'époque où je travaillais chez le
président Chirak en particulier. Je les
voyais régulièrement. On avait un
certain nombre d'idées qu'on partageait.
Je les ai je les ai beaucoup fréquenté
euh notamment quand j'étais cherpa parce
qu'il y avait un cherpa russe qui était
Igor Schouvalov qui est devenu ensuite
un premier vice-premier ministre russe
qui est maintenant gouverneur de
Tchukotka donc au fin fond de la Sibérie
qui sont les régions où il y a toutes
les terras russes qui est un proche de
Poutine qui était un homme extrêmement
délié parlant un anglais absolument
parfait et on travaillait bien. C'était
l'époque où on démantelait les
sous-marins nucléaires qui étaient basés
à Mourmansque. C'est dégueulait partout.
C'est ça comment qui dégueulait partout.
Qui dégueulait partout. Donc il fallait
éviter que effectivement il y ait une
dissémination de de nucléaire
pas de la prolifération mais que
effectivement la les déchets se
répandent et les Russes étaient tout à
fait je dirais à lande. On avait des
projets d'éducation commun, on avait des
projets de santé on avait des projets de
développement. Bref, les Russes étaient
rentrés dans une communauté qu'ils ne
connaissaient pas et à laquelle
finalement il finaient par s'habituer.
Euh, il faut dire que des gens comme
Schouvalov qui avaient été formé en
partie aux États-Unis avait avait une
habitude du monde occidental et donc il
y avait une certaine aisance, c'était
des gens très déliés. Donc, c'était
relativement facile de travailler avec
eux et de trouver des des voies de
coopération. Des amis russes ? J'ai des
j'ai des amis russes. Oui, absolument.
vieux des jeunes, des des vieux, des
jeunes. J'ai des vieux, des jeunes et
des gens qui sont en général très
ouverts, très russes, qui se sentent à
la fois européens mais en même temps pas
complètement européens parce que ce sont
les grands espaces, c'est une autre
conception de la vie.
Ils sont en général très idéalistes.
Enfin, je veux pas tomber dans les
clichés si mais les clichés sont souvent
des des portes d'entrée pour essayer de
comprendre un petit peu comment sont les
gens, comment ils sont façonnés. Jamais
cogné avec un SPnas parce que tu avais
un coup dans le nez. Je me suis jamais
cogné avec un spnat. Je sais par
ailleurs que les Russes n'aiment pas le
compromis, que les Russes ont une vision
de la mort qui n'est pas la nôtre. Un
jour, un russe m'a dit "Mais vous ne
savez pas mourir, nous nous savons
mourir." Je pense qu'il y a une approche
de la mort qui est de la vie qui est
très différente. Je pense sacrifice
alors et du sacrifice, je pense qu'il y
a des choses, c'est il y a il y a a y
pour quand j'étais dans tout ce métier
de diplomate que j'ai que j'ai mené, je
me suis attaché à une théorie que j'ai
que j'ai découverte un peu tard mais qui
était la suivante qui est la mémoire
collective émotionnelle des peuples. Je
crois que c'est quelque chose de très
important. Chaque peuple a une mémoire
collective émotionnelle. Comment j'ai
découvert ça ? J'étais à Londres à
l'époque euh et je je remets une
distinction à un professeur de
Cambridge, Julian Jackson. Et Julian
Jackson est un spécialiste de la France.
Il a écrit un livre qui s'appelle de
Gaulle, une certaine idée de la France
qui a été traduit. Et à l'époque euh
c'était dans les années 2010 euh il
avait écrit un livre qui s'appelait La
chute de l'Europe, The Fall of Europe et
dans lequel il racontait
la chute de l'Europe devant la Vermarthe
et ensuite comment devant toutes ces
occupations des mouvements de résistance
avaient été clos et notamment la
résistance française. Et je lui dis mais
c'est c'est très intéressant dans le
narratif que vous raconte que vous avez
mais est-ce que ça intéresse le public
britannique ? Il me dit "Mais c'est tout
à fait fondamental que le public
britannique
sache ce que c'est que de lutter contre
un ennemi qui occupe quand on est sous
la pote étrangère, il faut savoir
comment on réagit. Les anglais me dit-il
depuis Guillaume le conquérant en 1066
ne savent pas ce que c'est que vivent
sous une botte étrangère et c'est très
loin donc c'est une autre c'est c'est
une autre époque c'est un autre monde.
Il faut donc qu'il l'apprennent. Tous
les peuples de du continent européen ont
vécu un moment ou un autre après une
invasion sous une botte étrangère. Il
faut donc qu'ils apprent qu' ils et donc
ils ont dans leur dans leur psychologie
quelque chose qui les a marqué et chaque
peuple a une mémoire collective
émotionnelle. La résistance en fait
partie et beaucoup d'autres choses. Tu
as creusé un peu côté épigénétique ou
pas du tout ? Épigénétique ? Non, j'ai
pas creusé. Mais je pense que c'est une
question que j'ai posé à beaucoup
d'amis. Je leur ai dit "Mais toi tu es
d'origine italienne, c'est quoi la
mémoire la mémoire collective italienne
? Et un allemand quelle est sa mémoire
collective émotionnelle ?" et un et on
pourrait le poser un espagnol aussi. Un
espagnol il se souvient dans sa mémoire
collective émotionnelle dans sa relation
à la France qui est assez mêlé euh de
les invasions napoléoniennes. Ce sont
des choses qui ont profondément marqué.
Je crois que chaque peuple porte quelque
chose en lui. Quand j'étais ambassadeur
en Allemagne, j'allais souvent, je
faisais énormément de conférences, je
circulais beaucoup dans le pays pour
comme de le faire un diplomate,
c'est-à-dire porter un message du pays,
écouter ce qu'on dit. Je commençais mes
conférences en disant, "Je suis très
heureux d'être chez vous euh dans ce
pays où nous sommes souvent venus sans
invitation." Bon, ça faisait plaisir aux
gens parce que sommes toutes mes amis
allemands qui étaient en face, le public
qui était là se disait "Nous aussi".
Mais quand on va se promener Heidelberg
et qu'on voit la façade du château de
Heidelberg et qu'on sait que tout le
reste a été brûlé euh par les Français,
l'incendie du les incendies du Palatina.
J'ai une petite anecdote encore. J'étais
à Bonne à l'époque, donc 19890.
Je vais sur les bords de la de l'art qui
est une petite rivière. Je me suis dans
un bois un verre de vin blanc et je vois
une vieille qui criait derrière son
chien Méac Méac comme Malhe viens ici
Méac et Méac pourquoi il s'appelle
Méacche.
Méac était un des généraux de Louis XIV
qui s'est distingué par ses atrocités.
Ce qui fait que 300 ans après, il y a
encore des Allemands qui appellent leur
chien Mélac. J'ai trouvé cette anecdote
assez intéressante. C'est ça la mémoire
collective émotionnelle des peuples.
Elle ressort d'une manière ou d'une
autre, mais elle est là. Les Russes ont
une mémoire collective émotionnelle.
Elle est la mémoire d'un peuple qui n'a
pas de frontière et qui la doctrine de
Catherine I c'était étant dans le pays
pour se créer, je dirais une espèce de
glac. La notion de glac, elle existe
toujours aujourd'hui chez les Russes.
C'est pourquoi on dit bistro ? Oui,
c'est les c'était les les les Russes à
Paris en 1815 qui étaient pressés quand
ils avaient ils demandaient quelque
chose. Bestro, vite vite vite, ils
étaient pressés. C'est ça. Voilà. Et
donc euh l'idée les Russes donc ils ont
euh un territoire immense, ils ont une
notion du temps qui est sans doute
différente. C'est ce que disait madame
Carrière d'encos très souvent qui est
pour moi une référence dans la façon de
comprendre ce qu' a chez les Russes,
même si elle a pu faire des erreurs dans
ses interprétations. Elle a écrit des
elle a écrit une histoire des histoires
sur enfin des des livres sur le sur la
Russie dont dont on peut recommander la
lecture parce que ça reste très actuel.
s'est fait emmerder avant avant de
passer son l'arme à gauche pour avoir eu
ce ce type de position. Non. Oui, elle
elle a été très critiquée. Elle a été
très critiquée parce que on l'a accusé
d'avoir pris le parti de la Russie, ce
qui n'était pas exar. Elle avait une
vision nuancée des choses. Elle savait
ce que c'était qu'une violation du droit
international. Mais elle elle disait "Ne
croyez pas quand on était très
enthousiaste sur les victoires
ukrainiennes au départ, attention, la
Russie a le temps et l'espace. Pour moi,
c'est un élément d'analyse de base quand
on quand on parle de la Russie. profil
de ceux qui lui avaient cherché des
crosses.
Non, pas je fais pas des profils. Je ne
je vois un petit peu ce qui est ce tu me
parlais de la diplomatie. C'est quoi la
diplomatie aujourd'hui ? Le vrai sujet à
mon avis de la diplomatie, c'est de
prendre le monde tel qu'il est et de ne
pas se laisser aveugler par des
idéologies. Alors, il y a les idéologies
et il y a les valeurs. Nous avons des
valeurs. Les Français ont construit un
pays qui s'appelle la France sur des
valeurs qui sont celles de la Révolution
française, des Lumières. les valeurs de
la liberté, les valeurs de dignité et
cetera. On a construit là-dessus et tout
ça c'est dans nos préambules de
constitution. On a un corpus de valeur.
Mais
ça ne veut pas dire qu'on a une
idéologie. Une idéologie c'est une
interprétation du monde. Et je pense que
c'est extrêmement handicapant de
regarder le monde en pens avec des yeux
d'idéologue en pensant qu'il y a les
bons d'un côté, les mauvais de l'autre.
Il y a des faits. Ce n'est pas non plus
la réelle politique. La réale politique,
c'est du cynisme. Euh la politique, elle
a sa dose de cynisme. Mais
je peux te couper ? Vas-y.
Quand je t'entends parler,
tu flattes mes oreilles. J'ai un petit
cours d'histoire, j'ai des anecdotes,
mais j'ai l'impression, sans vouloir te
manquer de respect, vas-y, vas-y. Queil
y a un petit peu le côté boomer. Tu
c'est c'est-à-dire que on est au 21e
siècle, carrière d'encos se fait
chercher des crosses. Tu regardes pas le
profil des gens qui j'espère qu'il y a
des gens en France qui travaillent pour
la France qui ont fait le profil de ces
gens. Et voilà. Jusqu'à la coloscopie.
Tu as pas l'impression que nous la
France on s'est fait infiltrer par des
idéologies qui utilisent des relais de
soviétologue
surannée qui ont besoin d'exister
pour tordre notre perception et notre
capacité à prendre les bonnes décisions
pour protéger nos intérêts.
Alors, je te rejoins
euh largement sur ce que tu dis parce
que je pense que à mesure que le les
années ont passé et après avoir vécu la
période Chirak, on a quand même été
capable de s'opposer. La France est un
pays qui a su s'opposer. C'est la
tradition gauliste. De Gaulle a dit non
à un certain moment.
Nous av Il a dit non en 1958. Il a su
s'opposer euh et décider lorsqu'il s'est
agit de l'Algérie. Ce sont des moments
qui sont des moments charnières dans
notre histoire. Chirak a su dire non à
un moment où on nous embarquait dans une
guerre qui a semé le chaos 1 million de
morts dans le Moyen-Orient.
Petit à petit, nous nous sommes laissés
rattraper par une certaine facilité en
nous gargarisant du fait que la
diplomatie française finalement voyait
les choses de haut. et sans se rendre
compte et je reviens au départ de ce que
je disais, sans se rendre compte que
l'émergence d'un certain nombre de pays
nécessitait plus que jamais de notre
part un effort pour aller de l'un à
l'autre comprendre et travailler avec
eux. Alors même que dans le même temps,
nous nous sommes laissés rattraper par
des dépendances technologiques, des
dépendances militaires, nous sommes
entré dans le commandement militaire
intégré de l'OTAN, ce qui n'était sans
doute pas la meilleure idée parce que ça
nous a lié et alors qu'on avait gardé
Merci Sarkozy tout en étant dans l'OTAN,
c'est une décision de SarkoZi de
l'époque. En tant qu'ambassadeur,
j'étais à Londres à l'époque. Ça nous a
permis de nous rapprocher des
britanniques et d'avoir un très beau
traité qui s'appelle le traité de
Lancaster House où on partage des moyens
de défense avec les Britanniques, où on
partage également des instruments de
calcul de nos simulations nucléaires.
C'est une marque de confiance que nous
avons avec les Britanniques en terme de
dissuasion nucléaire. C'est essentiel
pour notre sécurité. S'il n'y avait pas
eu cette ce retour dans le commandement
militaire intégré, peut-être qu'on
aurait pas eu le traité de l'encaster
house. Bon, tout c'est c'est là où c'est
c'est complexe de juger à poster. Le
résultat aujourd'hui 2009, c'était le
retour dans le dans le commandant
militaire intégré. Aujourd'hui, je pense
qu'on y a perdu plus qu'autre chose.
Nous nous sommes perdus. Je parlais avec
des Libanais il y a il y a il y a
quelques mois qui me disent "Où est la
voix de la France ?" Qu'est-ce qui vous
distingue des autres ? Qu'est-ce que
vous dites de différent ? La France à
l'époque de De Gaulle et même si
l'époque n'appartenait à aucun bloc.
Aujourd'hui, il y a une espèce de
reconstitution, il y a eu avec la guerre
en Ukraine, la reconstitution d'un bloc
occidental qui aujourd'hui est en train
de se fissurer avec Trump. Et puis le
reste du monde, the west and the rest,
le reste du monde qu'on appelle le sud
global, que les Russes appellent la
majorité mondiale parce que c'est vrai
que par le nombre de personnes euh sur
la terre, c'est effectivement le plus
grand nombre.
Nous deux, nous avons des dialogues avec
un certain nombre de pays. Nous avons un
dialogue avec avec l'Inde, un dialogue
stratégique que j'ai mené d'ailleurs à
une époque, on a un dialogue avec la
Chine. On est en train de rétablir avec
certains autres pays, avec l'Égypte par
exemple tout récemment après la visite
du président Macron.
Mais nous ne sommes pas, je dirais, dans
la construction d'un monde nouveau avec
ces pays-là. Et c'est ça que la
diplomatie française devrait faire. Je
vois par exemple la Chine. La Chine
prône un ordre alternatif. Elle est à la
fois très orientée vers le
multilatéralisme. Elle tient aux
Nations-Unies, elle est assez contre une
réforme des Nations-Unies, mais
néanmoins, elle développe des idées par
une initiative globale de civilisation
dans laquelle elle dit "Mais euh est-ce
que euh la modernisation est
nécessairement l'occidentalisation ?"
C'est une bonne question. Euh elle a
prôé une initiative globale de sécurité.
Ça c'est surtout ne rentrez pas dans des
alliances. C'est une initiative qui est
antiutant et c'est destinée
vraisemblement à la région asiatique
essentiellement. Une initiative
de développement et là elle repit les
objectifs de développement global de
qui prenait un effort particulier d'ici
2030 qui ne sont pas tenus pour le
moment. Donc la Chine, elle est dans le
système multilatéral et un peu en marge.
Pourquoi n'avons-nous pas discuté de ces
initiative avec les Chinois directement
? Ne serait-ce que pour dire là-dessus
on est convergent, là-dessus, nous ne
sommes pas d'accord, nous ne sommes pas
au contact. Il y a des pans entiers du
monde que nous n'écoutons pas. Euh tu me
parlais de la guerre en Ukraine. Les
Chinois ont ont lancé des initiatives de
médiation. Alors on est dans l'idée la
Chine, la Russie, c'est pareil. D'abord,
c'est pas pareil la Chine et la Russie.
Il y a effectivement une un partenariat
sinorusse dans le cadre de cette guerre
en Ukraine qui est le partenariat de
deux voisins. Bon, est-ce qu'il durera
dans l'avenir ? On peut avoir des
doutes. Les Chinois regardent les Russes
comme une puissance colonisatrice,
anciennement puissance blanche qui leur
a pris union et demi de km carr un jour,
faudra régler les choses. Il y a des
cartes qui ont été réimprimées par les
Chinois en totalement en chinois qui
incluent Vladivostock. Donc le sujet
n'est pas réglé mais pour le moment ils
sont dans une alliance. Les Chinois
présentent ce plan de paix. Ils envoient
un émissaire, ils font un mauvais choix.
Ils prennent ils prennent un type qui a
été formé à Moscou qui ne parle que le
russe. Donc ça c'est pas très malin.
Mais en l'occurrence, ils envoient
quelqu'un qui présente un plan en 12
points. Dans ce plan euh de paix, il y a
le rappel de certains principes,
notamment la non agression,
l'inviolabilité des frontières
au titre de la charte repris de la
charte des Nations- Unies. Est-ce que
nous ne sommes pas d'accord avec ça ?
Deuxièmement, dans ce plan, il y a la
non reconnaissance de l'annexion des
territoires annexés par les Russes.
Est-ce que c'est pas quelque chose que
nous avons en commun avec les Chinois ?
Est-ce qu'on ne peut pas discuter ? Nous
n'avons même pas essayé de discuter.
Donc je crois que ça c'est c'est
dommage. Nous avons les Indiens comme
partenaires. Est-ce que nous parlons
avec les Indiens de ces questions ?
Suffisamment. Alors, il y a eu l'année
dernière, mais tardivement une mission
d'indiens ici et quand le premier
ministre Maudit est venu au début de
l'année, il a été question de ces de la
guerre de la guerre russo-rainienne.
Mais nous pourrions être à l'initiative
euh de la de réformes qui ne se font pas
dans l'ordre global international parce
que le vrai sujet de ces pays émergents,
c'est les institutions internationales
telles qu'elles existent, l'ONU, l'OMC,
ce qu'il en reste, ne reflète pas la
réalité du monde. Comment est-ce qu'on
rééquilibre ? On a un conseil de
sécurité qui ce sont encore les
vainqueurs de la deuxième guerre
mondiale. Est-ce qu'il n'y a pas un
moyen de travailler avec d'autres sur
une réforme ? La France est pour cette
réforme, mais est-ce qu'on ne peut pas
la définir avec d'autres plutôt que de
le faire tout seul ? Voilà ce genre de
sujet. J'ai je vais parler pragmatique,
terre à terre et de terrain. Quand on
est au Kedoris, une maison que tu
connais bien,
tu peux pas avoir des copains partout
Maurice. Donc tu as forcément un copain
du Kedorse qui a des copains sur place
pour te tenir au courant. Et quand ton
copain qui a pas les copains sur place
pour te tenir au courant avec des gens
qu'il connaît sur place avec qui il a
mangé bu, il connaît les problèmes de sa
femme et je te passe tes problèmes à
l'école de ses gamins, on envoie qui ?
ADGse,
nos antennes, nos oreilles, nos
moustaches.
Tu as pas l'impression que avec la
guerre en Ukraine,
y compris à la DRM, on avait pas les
oreilles, on avait pas les yeux, on
avait pas les moustaches, on avait pas
les cerveaux, on avait pas la
prospective et on avait des soviettes de
plateau, télé, des soviétologues de
plateau télé, des astrologues de plateau
télé qui ont débarqué de je ne sais où.
pour nous raconter leur petite science
qui a pas l'air de faire grand-chose en
ce moment et que c'est à coup de fit en
avant de fit. Quand tu étais au qu
d'orsais, tu appelé le directeur de la
DGSE et tu dis "Bon Coco, tu as des
copains sur place parce que moi
j'aimerais bien avoir un peu plus
d'information
pour la France.
Comment ça se passe ? Quelle est ta
perception ? Ça, on a vu la guerre en
Ukraine venir.
Je ne sais pas si on a vu la VER en
La DRM, ils l'ont pas vu, hein. Alors,
il y a eu plusieurs choses qui sont
passées. Il y a eu ce qui s'est passé en
Afrique, il y a ce qui se passe au
Moyen-Orient. Euh bref, on a des
services de renseignement. Me dire
qu'ils sont surchargés de travail, qu'on
a pas recruté les bons, qu'ils sont pas
assez payés.
Nous avons des services de renseignement
que j'ai fréquenté dans ma vie comme
tous les diplomates, comme tous les
ambassadeurs. Nous avons dans les
ambassades évidemment des gens qui font
du renseignement.
J'ai eu des bons, j'ai eu des moins bons
un peu. C'est la règle je dirais
humaine. C'est la règle statistique. Il
y a des bons, il y a des moins bons. Il
y a des types qui sont affutés, il y a
des gens qui ne le sont pas. En général,
j'ai en de bonnes relations avec eux.
Euh je crois qu'il y a euh souvent en
France des silos, des entonoirs dans
lequels il y a beaucoup de pertes en
ligne et sans doute peut-être pas la
sensibilité politique et la la remontée
du terrain. Ce qu'on observe dans
beaucoup de services de renseignement,
on l'a observé d'ailleurs dans l'affaire
du 7 octobre, c'est que le renseignement
technique prend le pas de plus en plus
sur le renseignement humain et que le
renseignement humain reste ce qu'il y a
de plus précieux. l'homme de terrain.
Alors, on fait des économies, on dépense
beaucoup d'argent dans des systèmes
d'écoute de toute nature. Euh et puis on
a moins de gens sur le terrain qui vous
ramènent de l'info. Ça vaut aussi, j'ai
des amis qui ont été dans les services
de de renseignements intérieurs,
l'ancienne DST, les renseignements
généraux et autres.
Ce sont des gens qui disent que nous
n'avons plus aujourd'hui ce qu'on
appelait des indiques. Les diplomates,
ils ont aussi des indiques. On écoute,
on compare, on croise l'information, on
fait de l'analyse. Alors euh c'est vrai
que s'agissant des plateaux télé, je
suis comme toi, je suis extrêmement déçu
par des ce que j'entends quelquefois
pris par des gens de ton ancienne
maison.
Je suis à il faut il faut être je ne
citerai personne. Il y a des gens qui
sont très bons, il y a des gens qui le
sont moins. Il faut travailler
l'information c'est quelque chose qui
n'est pas l'impression qu'on a c'est pas
la la confraternité au cloret. Il y a
pas il y a très peu de confraternité
parce que nous sommes peu nombreux et
chacun en fait pour dire la vérité se
tire labour pour être là où l'autre ne
sera pas. Ça il faut le dire. Il y a
néanmoins un sentiment de un sentiment
collectif, je dirais, de ce quel métier
de diplomate de ces de ces de ces
grandeurs, de ces servitudes. Ça nous le
partageons. Ensuite, reviens avec les
fins limé là parce que bon, comment
reviens avec les fins limées de terrain
pour prendre des bonnes décisions. Bah,
les fins liés de terrain, il faut Moi,
je me rappelle quand j'étais quand
j'étais en Chine ou quand j'étais en
Angleterre qui sont des pays très
difficiles. Je parle même pas du Japon
euh parce que le Japon c'est c'est
opaque mais les enjeux au Japon
n'étaient pas de la même nature que ceux
queon pouvait avoir en Chine ou qu'on
pouvait avoir en Angleterre. J'avais des
gens de toute nature que j'écoutais. Ils
ils certains étaient faisaient du
renseignement mais très peu. J'écoutais
tout le monde, j'entendais.
C'est ce que disait Taleran dans un de
ses livres. Talérant euh qui avait été
l'élève de Bourrienne avait écrit une
lettre en disant "J'ai appris avec vous
qu'il faut aller dans les fêtes car
c'est là qu'on y apprend les choses."
Bon et ben oui, il faut écouter, il faut
sortir de sa chambre. Et d'ailleurs, je
disais à mes à mes jeunes diplomates, je
leur disais "Mais ce qui compte, votre
plus-value, elle est pas d'être derrière
votre écran et de me faire une note.
Elle est d'aller sur le terrain, de
rencontrer des gens, d'écouter, de vous
promener, d'avoir le nez en l'air, de
voir un peu, de prendre la température
des événements. Alors, quand on arrive
sur des grands événements comme le
l'Ukraine et la Russie, là on monte à
des niveaux qui sont bien supérieurs. Il
y a eu quelque chose sur lequel je n'ai
toujours pas d'explication. Il y a eu
cet ultimatum comme on l'a appelé lancé
par les Russes fin 2021 où ils envoient
à l'OTAN et aux États-Unis des demandes
qui nous paraissent extravagantes.
Reculer les frontières de l'OTAN à 97.
Euh c'est leur façon de négocier. C'est
leur façon Mais alors justement reculer,
reprenons enfin établissons un système
de sécurité enfin quelque chose
d'extrêmement dur. Au même moment ils
accumulent 150000 hommes à la frontière.
vieille méthode de l'Union Soviétique de
toujours où on met la pression militaire
et en même temps on lance une
négociation diplomatique.
Ça n'a pas eu de suite. Il y a eu deux
trois conversations de madame Wendy
Sherman qui était le numéro 3 la
directrice politique du département
d'État et du du vice-ministre russe et
puis des discussions. Alors, nous avons
soi-disant, je n'étais plus en fonction
mais d'après ce que je comprends, nous
avons été informés mais nous n'étions
pas parti prenantes. Et comme le dit le
président Loula dans une lettre qu'il
avait fait publier au monde, si les si
les Américains étaient si sûrs qu'il
devait y avoir une invasion de
l'Ukraine, pourquoi est-ce que le
président Biden n'a pas pris son avion
pour aller à Moscou et dire à Poutine
comment est-ce qu'on règle le sujet ? On
a laissé la guerre se déclencher. Je dis
pas que les Américains ont déclenché la
guerre parce que certains vont vite pour
le dire mais je dis que on aurait pu.
Une guerre n'est pas fatale. Ça c'est ma
conviction de diplomate depuis que je
suis rentré dans ce métier. Il y a
toujours un moment on peut mettre le
pied pour interrompre l'enchaînement des
événements. Après, il faut trouver la
marche arrière. Alors après, il faut
trouver la marche arrière évidemment. Il
faut le faire en ayant la marche arrière
en tête mais on peut enrayer une guerre.
Après ça, il faut négocier. Le problème,
c'est le coût politique parce qu'il y a
dans tout pays des faucons et des
colombes. Il y a des gens qui poussent,
il y a des gens qui retiennent et c'est
aux dirigeants de faire l'équilibre. Je
pense que c'est ce qui se passe encore
aujourd'hui. Un président comme le
président Singping a des colons et des
faucons. Il y a des colombes qui qui
disent "Calmons-nous parce que une
guerre quelle qu'elle soit contre les
États-Unis pour Taïw ou la mer de Chine
du Sud nous mettrait en péril." Il est
en revanche des gens qui lui disent
"Allons-y, cassons-leur la figure." Je
pense que Poutine, ça c'est ça a été
rapporté aussi à des gens qui disent
"Mais sur l'Ukraine, allons-y carrément,
tapons à fond." Et puis d'autres qui
disent "Il est temps il est temps
d'arrêter." un dirigeant, et ça je l'ai
vécu de près dans des situations qui
n'étaient pas de guerre, mais avec euh
avec euh le président Chirak que dans le
bureau duquel je me suis trouvé
plusieurs heures par jour pendant 5 ans,
euh il y a des gens qui poussent dans un
sens, il y a des gens qui poussent dans
l'autre et c'est au dirigeants d'avoir
je dirais l'armature et la colonne
vertébrale pour tenir la route avec un
objectif. Tu as tu as pas l'impression
que alors c'est pour ça que je te pose
la question,
il y a quelque chose qui a changé que en
fin de compte on n plus maître de notre
destin parce que nos institutions censé
prendre la température, censé nous
informer, censé nous faire remonter de
l'information, on est vérôé par des
gens, des puissances étrangères, que ce
soit les Russes, les Américains, les
Anglais, les Qataris, les Marocains, les
Israéliens et la liste est longue qui
pousse en activant avant des petits gens
à gauche, des petits gens à droite dans
nos institutions pour faire remonter
l'information qui va bien dans leur
sens. Alors, est-ce que il y a encore un
filet de sécurité ? Deuxème question.
Quand quand
élevé un fin limier, un rotweiler croisé
tquel malinois doc de Bordeaux sous
stéroïd
que tu l'emmènes à la chasse mais qu'il
a jamais l'opportunité d'être félicité
quand il ramène du sang. H qu'est-ce qui
se passe avec ce fin limier ? Il arrête
de chasser ou il t'attrape à la gorge ?
Je crois qu'il faut le vrai sujet, c'est
la fluidité de la de la circulation de
l'information. Quand j'étais quand
j'étais à l'Élysée,
Chirak avait donné beaucoup d'importance
aux conséquences qui aurait pu être qui
était celle de la guerre en Irak qui
bouleversait tous les équilibres de la
région, qui bouleversait les pays
voisins, la Syrie. Et il m'avait envoyé
voir Bachar Elassad pour dire à Bachar
Alassad, attention, il va se passer des
choses. Donc commencez à réagir, prenez
des initiatives. Et puis il y avait une
initiative vers l'Iran.
euh initiative qui a qui était après la
découverte d'un programme iranien caché
par la IEA dont les Iraniens ne sont
jamais sorti, il faut quand même le le
le reconnaître, ce qui n'est pas le cas
de la Corée du Nord à cette époque et et
c'est toujours le cas, euh ils ne sont
pas ils sont toujours dans la IA, donc
il y a toujours des contrôles qui se
font, mais on avait découvert un
programme caché et ce programme caché,
on s'était dit bon ben les Iraniens vont
aller vers l'arme nucléaire. Donc
comment essayer de négocier avec eux une
manière dans le respect de leur
souveraineté ? Parce que finalement
après tout, j'ai le droit de m'armer
comme je veux mais qu'est-ce qu'on peut
leur donner en contrepartie
de d'une renonciation finalement à
acquérir l'arme nucléaire qui est une
obsession iranienne depuis l'époque du
chat et qui se poursuivra encore
longtemps. Pour le moment, ils sont
fatigués. Il y aura peut-être un accord
avec les Américains. Dit qu'ils l'ont
pas.
Ils ne l'ont pas parce que ils ont ils
ont effectivement de l'uranium enrichi
bien au-delà de ce qui avait été dans
l'accord du GCPOE. Il faudrait qu'ils
aient l'uranium rich à 90 %. Pour le
moment, ils n'ont qu'à 60 % donc a
priori, ils l'ont pas. Mais quand on est
à quand le jour ils sont à 90 %, il leur
faut très peu de temps pour pouvoir
construire une bombe nucléaire. Bref,
pour le moment, ils l'ont pas. Donc on
essaie de lancer cette négociation.
Là, nous avons je dirais fait travailler
toute la machine de l'État. Je me
rappelle de Réunion, je ne sais pas si
ça se produit encore aujourd'hui comme
ça où le conseil diplomatique que
j'étais avait à ses côtés des gens du
secrétariat général de la défense
nationale, avait des militaires, avaient
des gens des services de renseignement
militaire, avait
les scientifiques, avaient le CEA, avait
tous les gens qui avaient la
connaissance de ce sur quoi on pouvait
travailler dans le cadre de la
négociation. Moi, j'étais pas
négociateur mais on préparait la
négociation de cette façon-là. Ça a duré
assez tard parce que je dirais quand on
est arrivé à l'accord du JCPOE en 2015,
Fabius étant ministre, euh on a
travailler dans la technique. Euh je me
pose aujourd'hui la question de savoir
comment les Américains préparent cet
accord nucléaire euh avec un délégué
comme Witkov qui est un promoteur
immobilier et comme chef de délégation
ayant face à lui un ministre iranien qui
est le négociateur de la négociation
précédente. Fin de ces journées,
ministre des affaires étrangères, tu
arrives à endormir ? il n'est plus. Donc
la question quand il était, tu faisais
des petits loopings dans ton lit, des
bonnes siestes ? C'était j'étais je
n'étais plus en activité sous l'exomil.
Je n'étais plus en activité mais je
lisais, j'étais un peu inquiet parfois
parce que je pense que dans ce
métier-là, je parlais du ministre
d'affaires étrangères iranien Arakchi
qui a une longue expérience. Regardons
Lavrof, regardons Wi, regardons J S
Chankar en Inde. Ce sont des types qui
font la même chose depuis 20 ans, qui
sont dans des positions ou
d'ambassadeurs aux Nations- Unies ou de
ministres ou de secrétaires généraux de
leur ministère qui sont des types qui
ont qui sont cuits et recuit dans le
travail diplomatique avec la mémoire.
C'est un travail de mémoire aussi. La
diplomatie, c'est un travail d'histoire,
c'est un travail de géographie, c'est un
travail de psychologie, c'est un travail
de mémoire. Se rappeler que sur tel
sujet, on avait dit telle chose à tel
moment, que si on dit ça, immédiatement
la réaction sera celle-là. Quels sont
les impasses ? Quels sont les les
détours possibles ? Qu'est-ce qui a été
utilisé ou pas ? C'est ça, c'est un
apprentissage. Bon et en l'occurrence le
tu me parlais du fonctionnement avec les
liniers. Les limers on les met en ligne
au moment et on se sert d'eux parce
qu'ils sont utiles. On les valorise, on
les félicite quand il ramènent
effectivement de la chair, quelque chose
qui nous permet d'avancer. Quand il
ramène de la merde, tu fais quoi ? Bah
quand tu ramènes de la merde, tu te dis
que le type est mauvais et donc tu ne le
reprends pas. D'accord ? Mais tu le
reprends pas ? Est-ce que tu prends le
mec qui l'a sélectionné, élevé
et mis dans le Est-ce que tu fais par
exemple toute la branche
qui a amené ça ? Tu dis toi, toi, toi,
ça dégage.
C'est tout. C'est un problème général de
de la récompense et de la sanction dans
la fonction publique, c'est tout. Et
donc euh ça ça dépend des chefs, ça
dépend de l'impulsion qui est donnée
d'en haut, euh ça dépend de la manière
dont cette impulsion est répercutée à
tous les échelons. Euh c'est un
ensemble, c'est un comme on dit
aujourd'hui un écosystème euh avec une
chaîne de commandement. Euh si euh tu tu
as des gens qui sont médiocres et qui
deviendront très très bons parce qu'ils
auront un très bon chef qui saura les
mobiliser. Voilà. Est-ce que tu as des
gens très médiocres et qui viendront
très très importants parce qu'ils savent
bien lécher des rais ?
Ça a toujours existé. Si tu lis les
mémoires du Saint-Simon, tu te rends
compte que ça a toujours existé. Les
mémoires de cours, quand tu lis les
mémoires du prince de ligne que je viens
de relire très tout récemment, tu te
rends compte que oui, la courtisanerie
fait partie de l'environnement du
pouvoir. C'est au dirigeant lui-même
d'être lucide sur les courtisans qui
l'entour. Tu penses que Macron il est
lucide encore ?
Macron a une et là de pour son a fait un
2e mandat avec une conception de l'État
qui est la conception qui est la sienne.
Euh pour dire une chose, pour dire une
totologie. Ah, je sens le diplomate.
Non, je je pense que nous assistons
aujourd'hui à un affaiblissement de
l'État. Je pense que pour dire les
choses comme je les comme je les ai
vécu, euh autant l'esprit de corps est
néfaste parce que l'esprit de corps
c'est on est entre soi, on se sert au
détriment de l'intérêt public. En
revanche, l'esprit de corps, il a un il
donne un sentiment très fort
d'appartenance et de responsabilité par
rapport au groupe auquel on appartient.
avoir mis fin au à l'existence du corps
diplomatique qui était en fait un qui
constituait je dirais le canal d'un
apprentissage. J'ai toujours pensé que
pendant les 10 15 premières années de la
vie d'un diplomate, on apprend, on est
en apprentissage avec un chef qui est
très bon. Donc on va suivre ce qu'il
vous dit où il est très mauvais, on ne
refera pas les imbécilités qu'il vous a
commandé de faire. On apprend et après
on vole de ses propres ailes. Euh donc
c'est l'apprentissage et ensuite on
continue, on crée.
Les préfets, je pense que c'est la même
chose. Avoir supprimé le corps
diplomatique et le corps préfectoral
aboutit à l'affaiblissement de l'État.
Les quand tu construis une maison,
ton électricien, ton plombier, ton
maçon, ton plâtrier ne sont pas
interchangeables. Je pense que dans
l'État, il y a des métiers de
spécialité. Alors, on dit toujours que
la diplomatie, on peut en faire, il
suffit de parler, de l'ouvrir. Non,
regardons les diplomaties de nos
collègues étrangers, regardons la nôtre.
Euh il y a des diplomates qui
connaissent leur métier parce qu'ils
l'ont appris au fur et à mesure euh à
blanchir sous le harnet. Ils savent
s'entourer. Alors c'est pas une question
de grade vous, c'est une question de
d'assumer sa responsabilité et d'être
entouré de gens qui vous sont utiles.
J'ai eu la chance dans les ambassades
que j'ai eu euh d'avoir des très bonnes
équipes. Je fallais les motiver mais ils
étaient motivés par eux-mêmes. On
arrivait à faire quelque chose. Chacun
joue son rôle, chacun apprend. Et
l'ambassadeur, il tire son information
de partout. Euh donc toi tu es mon fin
limé à moi en fait parce que nous on
paye des impôts. Tu es payé par nos
impôts, tu as tu as bien animé ton
ambassade, tu as bien fait remonter de
l'information de terrain. Donc tu es mon
fin limier. Toi j'ai sûrement fait des
erreurs. J'ai sûrement fait des fautes.
Évidemment fin limier. Ce croisement
entre un doc de Bordeaux, un Rotveller,
un Tquel, un malinois, un scher et un
bulldog français.
Tu as pas l'impression que on t'a envoyé
chasser
et que tu as ramené du faisant, de la
perderie
et que le mec qui va manger ça, il
comprend pas, il sait pas l'exploiter ou
il est intoxiqué.
Je prendrai un exemple qui pour moi
constitue une des déceptions. J'avais
j'étais à Pékin en 2015 quand les
Chinois ont lancé leur plan Made in
China 2025 dont tout le monde parle
aujourd'hui. Il s'agissait en Chine de
créer 10 champions nationaux en
mélangeant le civil et militaire. 10
champions dans la la fibre optique, les
biothèques, les semi-conducteurs,
l'intelligence artificielle, bref tout
ce qu'on peut imaginer. 10 secteurs à
partir de là de faire avec les moyens
combinés de ces de ces champions des
champions mondiaux. Aujourd'hui, nous
nous trouvons avec une Chine qui sur le
plan de les hautes technologies est au
coude à coude si ce n'est devant les
Américains. Et le grand jeu entre la
Chine et les États-Unis, il se joue sur
les hautes technologies. C'est un
combat, je dirais, de titan pour savoir
qui va être le premier dans ces
technologies, qui va écraser l'autre et
surtout qui va imposer ses normes. En
2015, j'avais une équipe de PSOC
notamment au services économique
régional. Euh j'avais des spécialistes,
j'avais des types très doués. On a fait
des analyses extrêmement précises de ce
qu'était le plan chinois. Ce plan
chinois 2025, on y est. Je ne suis pas
sûr que ce plan chinois a été lu avec
l'attention qu'il méritait. Et avec les
explications qu'on avait pu donner, on a
mis on a mis des semaines et des
semaines à le je faire l'avocat du
diable.
Nous, on a mis en face le haat de la
licorne magique qui s'appelle Lorio la
Frenchstech.
C'est pas magique.
Alors moi je j'ai vécu la Frenchetech
aussi. La Frenchtech en Chine. La
Frenchtech à Shenjen. La Frenchtech
Frenchtech. J'aspire des subventions. La
Frenchte c'est fake it until you make
it.
Dans la Frenchtech, on sait très bien
que sur 10 projets, il y en a un seul
qui survivra peut-être. Il y a cette
envie très rapide de faire de l'argent.
J'ai un truc et puis dès que ça marche
un peu, je le revends. Bon, il y a il y
a pas la durée le patriotisme
et puis mais ça il y a pas le
patriotisme. Il y a aujourd'hui un
phénomène global qui est un phénomène de
société qu'on rencontre partout aussi
bien dans la vie privée que dans la vie
publique que dans les sociétés que dans
les grandes administrations qui est
l'individualisme. C'est chacun pour soi.
Et donc comment faire vivre l'esprit
collectif ? Ça c'est un grand grand
sujet. Merde, on est la France. On est
la France. J'ai eu beaucoup de
collaborateurs avec moi, beaucoup de
gens dans mes équipes qui étaient qui
avaient la France cheville au corps,
mais la France cheville au corps qui
était prêt à se faire défoncer euh pour
qui ne comptait pas ces heures. Je pense
qu'il y a des époques qui ont été
néfastes euh quand j'ai vu introduire et
je le dis comme je le pense, les 35
heures dans les ambassades alors même
que il y a des indemnités qui sont
versées pour un service permanent, je
dirais de nuit comme de jour. Quand j'ai
vu la RTT interduite, c'est j'étais
ambassadeur au Japon à l'époque, je me
suis dit il se passe quelque chose parce
que j'avais des j'ai eu des des des
agents euh qui m'ont dit "Ben aimer RTT,
pas tous." Comment on dit mourir de
travail au Japon ? Je ne sais pas mais
karaoshi.
Kalauoshi peut-être mais bon en
l'occurrence je pense que ce sont on a
en
le ma conviction pour l'avoir vu, pour
avoir défendu, pour avoir promu la
France et les produits français. Nous
sommes un peuple de grands travailleurs.
Les Français sont des travailleurs. On
n'a pas construit Notre Dame, toutes nos
cathédrales, l'artisanat qu'on a
développé, les techniques qu'on a
inventé. Euh si on regarde le registre
des inventions françaises, c'est
absolument incroyable. C'est le fruit
d'un travail acharné. Quand on regarde
ce que fait encore notre artisanat,
c'est extraordinaire. Quand on regarde
la reconstruction de Notre Dame, c'est
le fruit d'un travail acharné. On a mis
dans la tête des Français que les
loisirs, enfin de certains français que
les loisirs pouvaient être plus
importants que le travail. Et là, il y a
une perte en ligne qui est absolument
dramatique et que malheureusement à
contaminé un certain nombre de secteurs,
il contamine aussi l'État. Donc, il faut
que l'État se reprenne mais ça ne peut
passer que par la tête. Il faut que la
tête soit exemplaire, que la tête montre
Je dis pas qu'un chef un chef d'état ne
travaille pas, il travaille énormément.
Il a pas une minute à lui mais c'est
tout un état d'esprit. C'est comment le
poisson pourri ? Comment tu sais comment
le poisson pourri ? Pourri par la tête.
Le poisson pourri par la tête. Je crois
que c'est un proverbe chinois à
l'origine au vietnamien. Enfin les
endroits où on consomme beaucoup de
poissons. Si je te dis on a le droit de
perdre mais on n pas le droit de se
faire surprendre.
Je je ne sais pas si on a le droit de
perdre mais on a sûrement pas le droit
de se faire surprendre. Et normalement
avec les systèmes d'alerte que nous
avons et que nous devrions avoir à
travers tous nos systèmes d'information,
que ce soit les diplomates, que ce soit
les systèmes de renseignement dont tu
parlais tout à l'heure, civil,
militaire, on doit pas être pris par
surprise. Et être pris par surprise, ça
arrive à beaucoup de pays. Regardons
Israël qui a été pris par surprise le 7
octobre et qui pourtant est surarmé,
armé jusqu'au dents avec tous les
systèmes possibles d'alerte. Euh
être pris par surprise, c'est humain. Il
y a de grands exemples au Moyen-âge de
de citadelles qui ont été prises par
surprise par la ruse. La ruse fait
encore partie de la vie. La ruse dans la
guerre, la ruse dans la diplomatie,
c'est quelque chose. Alors ça ça prend
la ruse, ça s'improvise pas. Ça fait
partie du jeu. Tu trouves qu'on est rusé
nous ? Non, je pense qu'on n'est pas
assez rusé et je pense qu'aujourd'hui on
ne sait plus prendre de face le rapport
de force. Où sont les bad boys, les
rusés, les mauvais garçons ? Tuen vois
là ? Il y en a pas. Il y en a pas. Je
pense que nous ne savons pas nous
opposer. J'avais aujourd'hui, je
déjeunis aujourd'hui avec un garçon qui
est dans une grande entreprise publique.
Il me disait : "Nous ne savons pas nous
opposer, nous ne savons pas dire non.
Nous avons des atouts, nous ne savons
pas nous servir des des procédures de
droit mis à notre disposition par
l'Union européenne pour battre un
concurrent qui n'a pas être là dans un
pays où nous avons un projet.
Euh c'est nous sommes trop timides, ça
je le je le considère ça. Nous ne
voulons pas nous ne recherchons pas la
confrontation. Alors enfin nous voulons
éviter la confrontation plutôt. Il
s'agit pas de la rechercher, il s'agit
de l'éviter. Sauf qu'on n'est pas
chinois mais pour éviter la
confrontation, il faut être usé.
Voilà, il faut faire la guerre. C'est
comme un chinois. Un chinois c'est ssu.
C'est faire la guerre. Pour gagner la
guerre, il faut éviter de la faire. Mais
encore faut-il agir. Je pense qu'on
n'utilise pas au maximum de leur
potentialité les outils qui sont à la
disposition de l'État et ça vaut
partout.
On a on a des lames mais pas très
affutées. On revient un petit peu sur
l'Ukraine. La Russie l'a monté l'a monté
en en tension, en pression. Donc tu me
disais que ils avaient mis 150000 hommes
à la frontière.
Bah c'était c'était 2022. Bon, depuis on
a eu on a eu ce soutien massif des
États-Unis
et de l'Union européenne. Avant avant
les 1500 hommes, ils avaient fait des
petits signes précurseurs de on est en
train deah avant les s'énerver avant les
150, il vous aviez été chialés dans
quelle dans quelle institution
internationale ? Qu'est-ce qu'ils
avaient fait comme manœuvre militaire ?
Qu'est-ce qu'ils avaient fait comme
manœuvre pour inspirer de l'Iran pour
sortir de Swift ? Qu'est-ce qu'ils
avaient fait comme manœuvre pour sortir
d'Internet ?
Les Russes pratiquent, je dirais, le
hacking à fond, pratiquent les attaques
cyberes et c'est aujourd'hui un des
sujets centraux. Tu en as parlé
s'agissant de l'influence qu'on peut
avoir sur les opinions et sur lequel il
faut qu'on ait gérer tous les outils en
défense et en contreattaque. Branquignal
qui ont en France qui parlent de
guerrier hybrid qui brassent des grands
concepts et surtout qui ont le physique
de l'enfant. Je serais moins sévère que
toi. Mais c'est pas une histoire d'être
sévère. Nous, on parle en terme de
résultat.
On compare les résultats, on compare le
degré d'infiltration
quand on voit des pécors
aller faire des conférences au collège
interarmé de défense. Ouais. Des pécors
qui écrivent des livres à base de fich
Wikipédia.
Le jour où le fin limier va s'énerver,
on va les faire courir. Non, non, mais
nous ne mobilisons certainement pas les
moyens qu'il faudrait face à la
détermination de ces pays à agir,
notamment par les moyens cyber. Ça c'est
incontestable.
On a, je suis pas sûr qu'on ait pris
conscience de l'ampleur de ce que ça
représente. La guerre cyber, c'est la
guerre majeure aujourd'hui.
La guerre satellitaire, la guerre cyber.
Alors, on l'appelle la guérbride où ce
qu'on veut. On est très fort pour créer
des mots et des concepts. Ça, je suis
d'accord avec toi. Dans le don on se
gargarise, le vrai sujet, c'est les
moyens. Gargarise en groupe, je sais pas
si tu as remarqué. Oui. Oui, absolument,
absolument. On se gargarise mais euh
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé avant 2022 ?
Oui, il y a eu des signes. Il y a eu
effectivement d'abord il y avait la
négociation de Minsk, Minsk 1, Minsk 2.
Budapest avant, c'est ça ? Alors, non,
Budapest cit 94. C'était une garantie
donnée par les Américains, les Anglais.
Bon, mais il y a eu les Russes n'ont pas
respecté que les Russes n'ont pas
respecté, mais les Américains, les
Anglais non plus, ils sont pas venus au
secours des Ils sont pas venus au
secours des des Ukrainiens quand les
Russes sont entrés dans le dans le
Donbas. C'était pas des Russes, des
petits hommes verts. Alors oui, mais en
l'occurrence, j'ai assisté à une séance
de des des de Minsk en remplacement du
ministre euh à l'époque où j'étais à
Berlin. Il y avait une séance à Berlin.
Je dois dire que la mauvaise foi des
deux partis, russes et ukrainiens, était
incroyable. et il suffisait qu'il y ait
une avancée pour des des retraits
d'armes lourdes, des échanges de
prisonniers pour que immédiatement l'un
ou l'autre bombarde massivement de
l'autre côté, les Ukrainiens comme les
Russes. Et donc le programme c'était
précisément de ne pas aller jusqu'au
bout de Minsk dans l'idée des deux
parties. Est-ce que l'erreur des
Européens n'a pas été, il y a un livre
de Sylvie Koffman là-dedans qui qui est
une excellente journaliste au monde qui
a fait un livre sur la responsabilité
des occidentaux dans cette guerre. Je
pense que notre erreur français et
allemand qui étions les deux gars des
accords de Minsk dans les négociations,
c'est de ne pas avoir été trouvés les
Américains pour leur dire "C'est en
train de chauffer, ça va nous exploser à
la figure."
De c'est quelle année ça ? Ça c'était
2014 2015 16 17 jusqu'à 2022. Nous nous
on a vu des analystes en France
dire ça va chauffer, c'est une
poudrière, ça va nous péter la gueule,
ça va être un massacre.
Ils sont fait ennuyer. Non non mais ils
sont fait ennuyer sur notre territoire
et ils sont fait ennuyer sur notre
territoire par des gens français
sous l'influence
du bloc des F.
C'est-à-dire qu'on a rendu Borgne
et on a mis au chenil nos fins limés
avec une espèce de meut de petit pécor
nourri de la main des Five Eyes.
On a
on a précisément
on n pas je disais on n pas été chercher
les Américains pour leur dire ça va nous
exploser à la figure. Deuxièmement, on
n' pas continué à travailler
suffisamment avec cette organisation qui
s'appelait l'OSCE. L'OSCE,
c'est une c'est l'organisation de la
sécurité de la coopération en Europe qui
regroupe 54 pays dont la Russie. On a
coupé tous les ponts après 2014 avec les
Russes. On a plus parlé aux Russes. On a
fait en sorte que tous les canaux de
communication soient coupés parce que
c'est devenu une habitude française et
on le voit un peu partout dans notre
diplomatie. On ne parle pas à un tel
parce qu'il est trop comme si. On ne
parle pas à un autre parce qu'il est
trop comme ça. On pense qu'on parle à
tout le monde. Ce n'est pas vrai. On ne
parle pas à tout le monde, on se pince
le nez. À force de se pincer le nez, on
narrive plus à respirer. Ça c'est le
problème. Sentir ce qui va se passer. Et
on ne sent alors non seulement on ne
respire plus mais on ne sent plus ce qui
va se passer. Et là il y avait
effectivement des indices qui montraient
que c'était en train de se compliquer
sérieusement. Alors
2022, il y a eu effectivement cette
cette accumulation de troupe. Il y a eu
cet ultimatum, il y a pas eu de
négociation entre Américains et Russes
et les Russes sont entrés en Ukraine.
Les Russes sont entrés en Ukraine en
pensant mettre faire un bas sur
l'Ukraine. Rappelons-nous que quelques
mois avant, ils étaient allés en
Kazakhstan et ils avaient remis de
l'ordre au Kazakhstan. Je pense que les
Russes ont essuyé une sérieuse
déconvenue. Nous nous sommes tous unis.
Donc tout ça tout le monde connaît cette
histoire en pensant que l'Ukraine allait
gagner sur la Russie. Erreur
d'appréciation majeure aujourd'hui. Où
est-ce qu'on en est ? Je crois qu'on en
est à nouveau au point de départ. Je
regarde le mémorandum russe déposé le 2
juin dans les négociations à Istanbul.
Ce mémorandum, il reprend exactement les
points de 2021. Retrait sur les
positions de l'OTAN de 97, neutralité de
l'Ukraine, démilitarisation de
l'Ukraine, dénaasification de l'Ukraine.
Sur la dénazification, je pense qu'on
prend pas la chose assez au sérieux
personnellement. Pourquoi tu dis ça ? Je
dis ça parce que il y a à chaque
élection en Ukraine un petit parti
mineur qui représente entre 5 et 10 %
des voix qui est un parti des héritiers
de Bandera. Stéphane Bandera est un est
un nationaliste ukrainien qui a été
allié au nazis. Attention là on va te
dire que tu es prusse que tu sers les
arguments de Moscou que tu peut-être tu
touches du rou. Je Non, je ne sers pas
les arguments de Moscou. Je sers les
arguments de l'Europe pour la raison
suivante qui est que je ne vois pas
pourquoi nous pourrions admettre ce type
de partie avec des des gens qui sont
tatoués avec des croix gamés qui ont
constitué pour la plupart d'entre eux le
fameux bataillon d'Azovof qui s'est
battu à Mariol au début de la guerre
dont on ne sait pas où il est passé
depuis. Il y a quand même des avenues
Bandera. Il a des statutes de Bandera,
il a des gerbes de fleurs déposées au
monument de Bandera qui est quand même
quelqu'un qui je ne crois pas qui je
crois ne rentre pas dans les idéaux de
l'Union européenne à laquelle l'Ukraine
est candidate. Et donc je pense que si
on regarde les fameux critères de
Copenhag sur les droits de l'homme et
sur un certain nombre d'idées, je pense
que si on passe au crible ces critères,
l'Ukraine ne coche pas encore toutes les
cases. à moins qu'elle ne décide de
mettre fin à ce parti qui est quand
même, je dirais, un dérivé. Alors, na
tous les cas ultraationaliste et avec,
je dirais une un pédigré mêlé
de collaboration avec les nazis
ukrainiens, avec les nazis dans la
période ukrainienne, dans la période où
les où l'Allemagne où la Vermart était
en Ukraine. Donc des nazifications. Donc
je reviens, les Russes ne veulent
incesser le feu qu'à partir du moment où
des engagements sont pris sur tout ça,
des retrait des troupes ukrainiennes,
des régions occupées, bref maximaliste.
Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé depuis ?
Il y a donc ce mémorandum du 2 juin.
Pourquoi les Russes font-ils cela ? Ils
font cela parce qu'ils ont un avantage
stratégique dont plus personne ne parle
aujourd'hui et qui a sans doute poussé
les Américains à rechercher les voies de
la paix. Biden l'aurait fait comme Trump
l'a fait. Il y a eu novembre le tir par
la Russie d'un missile
noisette. Orchnik. Orchnik est un
missile Mirv qui est un descendant du
SS20 de la fameuse bataille des Perching
contre les SS20 des années 80.
Ce missile Orchnique vole à 13000 km
heure, résiste à des températures de
2000°gr à une portée de 5000 km et tire
dans une cible de 150 m. Ce qui veut
dire que tout ce qui est armement
nucléaire ou conventionnel et mêlé, on
peut avec un missile oréchnique détruire
un porte-avion, n'importe où, détruire
une usine, détruire une petite bourgade.
C'est d'une précision terrible. Pourquoi
il y a eu ce missile ? s ce missile
s'est développé parce qu'il n'y a plus
de contrôle des armements. Chacun fait
dans son coin ce qu'il veut ce qu'il
veut. Et donc les Américains et les
Russes dans l'agenda qu'ils ont mis au
point depuis les premières réunions de
février à Riad ont mis le contrôle des
armements. Mais ils n'ont pas encore
commencé à négocier. Mais bref les
Russes ont pris un avantage stratégique
qui est absolument considérable. Alors,
on a eu tout récemment le fameux euh
Spide Web ou Web Spiderm, le cheval de
TR extraordinaire. Cet envoi de drones
sur des aéroports lointains qui ont euh
mis en pièce des avions russes. On ne
sait pas exactement combien. Est-ce que
c'est des bombardiers stratégiques,
est-ce que ce sont des des chasseurs ?
Est-ce que on ne sait pas. Ce qui est
sûr, c'est que ils ont atteint des
cibles extrêmement lointaines. Ils ont
fait passer un message. Et ils ont fait
passer un message. Quel est le message ?
Le message, c'est que l'Ukraine a des
moyens euh je dirais techniques. Euh les
Ukrainiens sont très forts. Euh la base
euh la base technologique de l'URSS,
elle était largement en Ukraine. Merci
un peu les Britanniques. Et puis
ajoutons à cela, le renseignement
britannique, le renseignement américain
mais surtout britannique aujourd'hui.
Bref,
il y a pas que les britanniques, il y a
la capacité ukrainienne d'envoyer ces
drones. Des drones, quel est l'autre
message ? ils sont capables de frapper
n'importe où et qu'il y a peut-être des
containers qu'on qui ont déjà pris
position. Exactement. C'est un peu c'est
un peu ce qui s'est passé euh quand euh
Israël euh a piégé les les téléphones
portables et les tokiwoki du Esbola.
C'est c'est un peu comparable. Donc
c'est l'incertitude majeure. Les Russes
aujourd'hui sont en train de riposter.
Ils ne ripostent pas massivement. Les
Russes aujourd'hui sont en train de
pousser l'Ukraine à la capitulation.
Pour moi, c'est ma conviction intime.
Quand on voit les attaques de drone sur
KarkOf, c'est pas nouveau. La poussée
sur Carkof, elle existait déjà depuis
quelques temps. C'est quand même la
deuxième ville d'Ukraine avec de ou 3
millions d'habitants au nord-est à pas
très loin de la frontière russe. Quand
on voit la poussée sur Dipro sur le sur
le DPR Nepro Petrovsk
un hub extrêmement important. Les Russes
il faut repérer. Kerson c'est un hub.
Bahmou, c'est un hub. Ils ont pris des
zones de communication. C'est ça leur
stratégie. Et ça, il faut lire la presse
allemande pour bien connaître tout ça.
Les Allemands écrivent parfaitement ce
genre de choses. Je lis la presse
allemande tous les jours. Ils sont en
train de compter leur bunker d'ailleurs.
Ils sont en train de compter leur
bunkerers. Donc, ils avancent et
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait depuis
avanthier ? Ils envoient des ils
envoient des drones sur Kief et ils
envoient des drones sur Odessa. Odessa,
ça devient très grave parce qu'Odessa,
il y a la Moldavie à 14 à 150 km
derrière. Odessa, c'est le déboucher de
l'Ukraine sur la mer noire. Alors, une
partie a été récupérée, la Crimée a été
récupérée par les Russes et là, ils ont
un blancin des Américains pour la garder
quoi qu'il arrive. Et on peut y revenir.
C'est un sujet qui est très sérieux en
matière de respect de la souveraineté
des États. Mais il y a Odessa
aujourd'hui, les Russes ont mis mettent
le maximum pour pousser l'Ukraine à la
capitulation. Est-ce que nous sommes
prêts à soutenir l'Ukraine ? Ils savent
que nous n'avons pas les moyens de
soutenir l'Ukraine. Ils le savent. Ils
savent que les Américains, je vais faire
l'avocat du diable. Oui, on est la
grande Europe, on est tous ensemble. On
va faire une chanson pour Noël, on va
faire un crowdfunding, on va envoyer des
armes et on va battre les vilains russes
parce que c'est le camp du mal, c'est
les méchants. Tu comprends Maurice ?
Moi, je crois qu'aujourd'hui le
sujet c'est
d'arrêter cette guerre avant que ça
n'aille trop loin. Et je pense
personnellement et je suis étonné qu'on
l'ait pas encore fait que le seul
contact que ness à Poutine, c'est euh de
le le contact que Trump a eu avec lui.
Je ne comprends pas pourquoi les
Européens
ne sont pas en contact avec Poutine.
Je ne comprends pas pourquoi un pays
comme la France, membre permanent du
Conseil de sécurité et responsable à ce
titre
au nom de la charte des Nations-Unies de
la paix et de la guerre n'est pas en ne
prend pas contact. Alors évidemment ça
donit pas Maurice pourquoi ? Mais
Maurice non mais ça don l'impression
Stéphane s journé quoi. Ça donnerait
l'impression
il faut gérer l'opinion dans ces cas-là.
Ça vouit dire une rédition. Il s'agit
pas de ça. Le général de Gaul a dit à
très juste titre on ne construit pas
l'Europe contre la Russie. On construit
l'Europe avec ou à côté de la Russie. Et
aujourd'hui, nous sommes dans une dans
une dans une optique qui est une optique
de préparer la guerre. Il vient, il y a
une chose qui me frappe beaucoup, c'est
un manifeste qui sorti aujourd'hui au
SPD en Allemagne lancé par le le le
l'ancien président du groupe
parlementaire SPD de Scholz qui
s'appelle Mutsonich. Ils sont pas mal de
SPD. Il y a un congrès du SPD qui a lieu
à la fin du mois de juin. SPD pour ceux
qui ne savent pas, c'est le parti
social-démocrate. Ce sont donc les
socialistes allemands qui sont
aujourd'hui dans la coalition. La
coalition, elle est menée par Merz qui
lui est pour le réarmement allemand pour
les 5 % de PNB
consacré la défense 3,5 % pour la
défense strictins les armements 1,5 %
pour la rénovation des infrastructures
qui servent à la défense, les ports, les
ponts, les voies ferrées, les routes et
cetera, les bunkers
5 %.
C'est donc que une partie de du des
socio-démocrates
lance ce manifeste et quelque chose de
très sérieux. Qu'est-ce qu'ils disent ?
Ils disent "Il est absolument nécessaire
face à la Russie de renforcer nos
capacités de défense." En français, on
appelle ça comment ? Mais attends, mais
ce qu'il faudrait au même moment, c'est
non seulement renforcer nos capacités de
défense, mais lancer une négociation sur
le contrôle des armements. Il faut
doubler, il faut pas renforcer nos
capacités de défense pour dire "Nous
sommes prêts à faire la guerre". Il faut
les renforcer en les alliant avec une
manière de parler sur le contrôle des
armands. Le contrôle des arms, c'est
quoi ? Ça veut dire je vais placer tel
type d'armement à tel endroit, tel type
de tel type de missile, toi tu vas les
placer à tel autre endroit. On calcule
la portée. C'est c'est extrêmement
complexe. Gâchi de pognon et des deux
côtés. Oui. Mais bon, il il s'agit en
l'occurrence de montrer qu'on est plus
fort. Personnellement,
je j'irais jusqu'à dire que je ne sais
pas d'où viennent les évaluations sur la
menace. Je suis troublé parce que je
vois le chef du BND qui est le service
des renseign le DGSE allemand dire
"L'Ukraine n'est qu'un premier pas de la
Russie vers l'ouest. Donc préparons-nous
à la guerre."
Le BND, c'est quand même des gens
sérieux. D'un autre côté, je vois la
difficulté que les Russes ont à avancer
en Ukraine. Euh, c'est parce qu'il te
manque une clé de lecture, Maurice.
C'est-à-dire bah regarde, tu as écrit un
bouquin qui s'appelle comment déjà ? Les
autres ne pensent pas comme nous.
D'accord. Bon, mets-toi à la place d'un
russe 2 secondes, essaye. On a fait
péter Nord stream puis en plus on s'est
foutu de leur gueule. On a dit que
c'était eux qui avaient fait péter Nor
stream parce qu'ils voulaient plus
fournir de gaz. Ça c'est franchement
prendre les Russes pour des débiles
mentaux. Ils sont tellement procéduriés
qu'ils sont presque couper les deux m
pour respecter un contrat.
On a fait péter Norstream, on a dit que
c'était eux puis après on savait pas
puis après ben machin je t'en passa des
meilleurs. Donc premier couteau dans le
dos dans la tempe. Appelle ça ce que tu
veux. On leur on les a intoxiqué avec
l'Ukraine. Je te dis mets-toi à la place
du russe. Il s'estime intoxiqué, il
s'estime pas respecté. Il s'estime
encerclé.
Tu sais quand tu commences à danser avec
l'ours,
tu sais pas quand est-ce que tu ça va
arrêter de danser. C'est l'ours qui
décide. Oui, absolument. Quand pour
reformuler tes arguments un peu plus à
la française,
les Allemands, ils sont en train de se
chier dessus.
Ils ont plus d'énergie, vont marcher.
Ils sont coincés avec les accords de
Paris, avec Gretenberg, le charbon et je
t'en passer des meilleurs. Ils sont en
train de se faire dépesser par les
Chinois d'un côté, les Américains de
l'autre. Les Français ont encore le
programme thermonucléaire de du de
Charles. Ils se disent ou là là là, on
va claquer 40 % de notre PIB en armement
mais en face il y a les Russes et le
temps qu'on se réarme, faut mieux leur
faire croire qu'on va faire un petit
câlin câlin sur les sur les traités
d'armement. On va en créer on va en Tu
crois que les Russes ils vont ils vont
gober ça ce coup-ci ? Je pense que les
Russes,
je reviens sur ce que j'ai dit, il
s'agit pas d'être désarmé face aux
Russes, il s'agit effectivement de faire
un effort de réarmement. Nous avons
laissé filer beaucoup trop, je dirais,
cette dimension. On a on a eu les les ce
qu'on appelait les dividendes de la paix
parce que depuis 1990, on a que les
Américains s'occuperaient tout. Il y a
que les Français qui ont fait un effort.
Quand on regarde la loi de programmation
militaire, on a on a sur 5 ans 400
milliards d'euros qui sont prêt à être
dépensé et là-dessus, il y a 50
milliards pour la dissuasion nucléaire.
Il y a la il y a la modernisation de
notre missile M51 qui nous permet de je
dirais d'avoir d'exercer cette disuation
nucléaire. Donc nous sommes crédibles.
Les Allemands sont effectivement dans
une situation extrêmement différente.
Mais se réarmer ne veut pas dire
nécessairement
faire la guerre. Or, il y a aujourd'hui,
de mon point de vue, un petit bruit de
fond qui est on va en découdre.
Je pense qu'il est important en même
temps que tu te réarmes et en même temps
que tu es solide et que dans un rapport
de force, dans une négociation, tu te
prépare à discuter avec l'adversaire, il
est important au même moment de préparer
le contrôle des armements. On ne peut
pas continuer à avoir des missiles
oréchniques de l'autre côté en pendant
que nous nous n'avons rien ou bien
attendre 10 ans pour recommencer à
négocier. Il est important, je dirais,
de créer les conditions de la paix. Je
n'entends pas parler de la paix, je
n'entends pas parler des échanges, je
n'entends pas parler de coopération.
J'écoutais hier un discours du général
de Gaulle de 1960 dans lequel le un
moment d'une extrême tension euh de la
guerre froide. Euh c'était après ça ça a
été débouché en 62 sur la crise des
missiles de Cuba. On a failli avoir une
guerre nucléaire. Déjà de Gaulle à cette
époque
prône la détente. Ça existe la détente
c'est quelque chose qui existe. Pourquoi
est-ce que l'Europe n'assume pas
elle-même de prer la détente face au
Russes ? Pour ça effectivement, il faut
être armé pour prener la détente parce
que tu peux pas aller à poil. Tu as fait
le pédigré de nos élites européennes à
l'heure actuelle. Mais le problème c'est
que tu as fait leur pédigré dans quelles
universités qu'ils ont fréquenté par qui
ils sont fait tamponner avec qui ils ont
signé des contrats qui fait quoi ?
Comment ? C'est un argument que je
connais bien que les Allemands
développent souvent. C'est quoi le
pédigré de nos dirigeants ? Nos
dirigeants aujourd'hui, ce sont des
dirigeants d'une génération qui ne sait
plus ce que c'est que la guerre. La
mémoire collective émotionnelle de la
guerre ne les frappe pas.
J'ai été nourri, moi à ma génération au
lait, si on peut dire les choses, de la
réconciliation franco-allemande. Mon
père était officier, avait fait 5 ans de
flag. Mes deux grands-pères avaient fait
la guerre aussi, la guerre de 14 et la
2è. Et
chez nous, on disait les [__] Un
jour, je dis les [__] Les cheleus
quand même. Mince, on dis non, les
cheleux, c'est plus tard. On disait les
cheleus. Mais cette génération là, la
génération de la guerre de 14 disait les
[__] Et un jour, je dis les [__]
J'avais 10 ans. Mon père me reprend, me
dit "Je t'interdis de dire les [__]
Tu n'as pas fait la guerre, tu n'as pas
à dire les boches." Dis plutôt les
cheleux, mon fils. Bon, en l'occurrence,
j'ai donc vécu en ayant de la bouche du
cheval, comme beaucoup de français de ma
génération en direct ce que c'était que
la guerre. Aujourd'hui, on a une
génération qui n'a pas connu la guerre,
qui n'a pas connu le service militaire
non plus, qui n'a pas cette idée, je
dirais, de de l'armée nation. euh de la
l'idée de la collectivité. Je parlais
tout à l'heure d'un individualisme
grandissant, mais il est d'autant plus
débridé cet individualisme qu'à aucun
moment la notion collective n'est
arrivée. Qu'est-ce qu'on connaît de
l'État aujourd'hui ? Un jeune
d'aujourd'hui, il est ni meilleur ni
pire que ce que nous étions quand nous
étions jeunes. Mais qu'est-ce qu'il
connaît de l'État ? Rien. Il ne connaît
que les contraintes de l'État. Il ne
sait plus ce que c'est que passer une
frontière puisqu'on ne contrôle plus les
passeports dans l'espace Schengen. Tant
mieux. C'est la libre circulation. Il ne
connaît euh il ne connaît pas le service
militaire et les ordres d'un adjudant de
quartier. Euh il ne connaît que le fait
de payer des impôts. C'est la seule
contrainte qu'il a qui lui est imposée
par l'État. plus alors s'il est
entrepreneur alors s'il est entrepreneur
il a des normes, il a des papiers à
remplir, il a la paperasserie mais somme
toutes sans avoir l'idée de la
contrepartie que représente cette
paprasserie puisque effectivement il y a
quand même a priori un service public
qui lui est rendu en en échange mais
c'est très court il n'y a pas le
sentiment d'appartenance à la
collectivité je lis souvent des
témoignages de tous ces types qui se
sont battus des Je trouve dur avec les
jeunes non je suis pas dur avec les
jeunes je vais faire l'avocat du diable
pour les jeunes
Regarde-moi ces crétins. Une balance
commerciale à plus de moins mo- 130 ou-
156 milliards. Regarde quand on va à
l'hôpital 24 heures dans les urgences,
on dit réarmement démographique. Nous
les jeunes, on doit faire des gamins. Il
y a pas de crèche, il y a pas de
pédiatre, il y a pas d'obsteicien, il y
a plus d'infirmière où elles sont payées
aux lance-pierre. Quand il y a le Covid,
elle se balade avec des sacs poubelles
en guise de casac.
Quand on voit ensuite Bamboche à
Versaill, quand on voit nos élites,
le jeune il se dit "Ce pays est vérolé,
il est en train de crever, ils vont
m'emmener par le fond parce que on a une
gérontocratie qui a pris le pouvoir et
ils vont nous emmener par le fond. Alors
ma France, je l'aime mais vous aurez pas
ma peau. Oui. Oui. Non mais moi je je je
parle de la perte. Tu comprends
l'argumentaire du jeune ? Je comprends
l'argumentaire. J'ai eu cinq enfants,
j'ai 10 petits enfants. Donc je suis euh
j'ai euh j'ai un échantillon assez vaste
pour savoir, je l'ai dit, ils sont ni
pirrees ni meilleurs. Est-ce que
l'horizon qu'on leur offre, je dirais,
est satisfaisant ? Est-ce que ce qui ce
qui alors il y a l'engagement associatif
qui existe mais ce qui me ce qui me
préoccupe c'est le sentiment collectif
patriote et pour le pays. Qu'est-ce qui
reste ? Or on parlait de la guerre. La
guerre, c'est quelque chose qui engage
une collectivité nationale.
Aujourd'hui, on a l'impression que on a
perdu de vue de ce que ce que c'est que
la guerre et on est facilement
belliciste pour rien. Quand il y a très
peu et quand on dit par exemple queon
veut on peut enrayer la guerre, on te
dire mais tu es tu es partisan de
Poutine, tu es partisan de c de ça. Non,
le pédigré des gens qui font ça qui
disent ça. Fais le pédigré de A à Z.
Vas-y, fais-toi plaisir. Non, mais je me
fais plaisir. Je je cherche pas à me
faire plaisir. J'essaie de regarder. Je
ne veux pas je ne veux pas mettre les
gens dans des catégories si tu veux. Je
dis ça des catégories. C'est-à-dire
qu'il faut analyser qui a tel Alors, il
il se il ne se gêne pas pour catégoriser
faire des fiches sur les gens qui sont
contre la guerre ou qui sont prorusses
ou qui sont antirusses.
Bah tant mieux. Ma grand-mère disait
toujours "Méfie-toi des gens qui font
des fiches." Oui. Le problème, c'est
qu'ils font des fiches. Ils créent des
monstres
peut-être, mais en l'occurrence,
tu me parlais des jeunes, je pense qu'il
y a aujourd'hui un un un
énorme fossé entre,
je dirais, certaines générations qui ont
vécu certaines choses et la génération
qui suit. Et le problème c'est la
transmission. La transmission aux
générations qui suivent. C'est un
problème général dans le monde.
D'ailleurs, la transmission. Nous sommes
aujourd'hui dans une époque où nous en
Europe, nous ne savons plus ce que c'est
que la guerre. Nous ne savons plus ce
que c'est que la tension, nous ne savons
plus ce que c'est que la mobilisation
collective. Alors, on l'a vécu avec le
Covid un peu et c'est intéressant
d'ailleurs en Espagne là, tout récemment
quand il y a eu cette panne d'Internet
pendant 3 jours, tout de suite le
sentiment collectif revient. C'est
absolument. Panne de courant. Oui.
D'internet avec panne de courant lié à
l'internet. Enfin effectivement, mais
les gens du coup les gens se parlent
c'était lié au système de panneaux
solaires et auoliens. C'est ça. Bon et
et donc les gens se parlent dans la rue.
C'est extrêmement intéressant. Euh il y
a cette en Espagne aussi, je dis ça
parce que j'ai une fille qui vit en
Espagne, des petits enfants espagnols.
On les aime les espagnols. On les aime
les espagnols. Un très bon patin gras du
très très bon. À Valence, à Valence, tu
as ces inondations absolument
gigantesques. Toute l'Espagne vient
donner un coup de main. le fabricant de
jambon, le fabricant de pâte à gras sa
camionnette avec des péntation ou pas
parce queils ont construit dans des
zones artificialisées. Enfin, ils ont
ils ont artificialisé les sols et queil
y a plus les écoulements et qu'ils ont
et qu'ils ont bétonné la rivière. Ils
ont protégé un quartier. Ah, c'est bien
ça non ? Bref, revenons à nos moutons.
Revenons à nos moutons. Non, je le
sentiment collectif est quelque chose
qui est largement perdu et ça c'est un
vrai sujet. Alors, c'est pas pour mettre
en cause les jeunes. C'est vrai que ce
que tu as mentionné, les perspectives
qu'on peut offrir, l'organisation de
l'État, l'organisation du service
public, l'organisation de la société,
c'est quelque chose qui est qui est
problématique. Il y a un manque de
leadership en France et pourtant on a
des des pépites. Moi, je rencontre
beaucoup quand je fais des conférences,
je vois beaucoup de d'étudiants à qui
viennent qui ce sont des pépites, sont
des gens qui demandent qu'une chose,
c'est d'agir, c'est de regarder devant
et évidemment c'est c'est quelque chose
qui qu'on ne leur offre pas
nécessairement. Les sanctions, ça sert à
quelque chose. On va mettre l'économie
russe à genou en 2038.
Les sanctions, il y a 60 pays dans le
monde, une soixantaine de pays qui sont
sous sanctions. Les sanctions de qui par
qui d'ailleurs ? Sanction des
États-Unis, c'est Cuba les premiers. Ça
va jusqu'à la Syrie. On essaie de
l'élever maintenant. Corée du Nord un
peu. La Corée du Nord un peu, l'Iran, la
Russie depuis la guerre de 202 enfin
depuis 2014 puis ensuite 2022. L'axe du
mal. Les sanctions, c'est
un moyen d'exercer la pression sans
faire la guerre. Bon, mais les sanctions
aujourd'hui, le monde entier a compris
que c'est fait pour être détourné.
Il y a un livre passionnant d'une jeune
femme qui s'appelle Agath de Maret qui
s'appelle Sanction the backfire.
Sanctions the backfire, le retour de
flamme. Et aujourd'hui, même un certain
nombre de gens aux États-Unis, dans les
universités, mais je suis pas sûr que
les Trumpistes s'en rendent bien compte,
mais se rendent compte que les
sanctions, ça mobilise énormément
d'énergie de la part d'un certain nombre
d'administrations, de certain nombre
d'entreprises pour vérifier si on est
dans la compliance de ces sanctions.
C'est quelque chose qui ne fonctionne
pas. Regardons les sanctions qui ont été
appliquées à la Russie. Elles ont about
alors elles ont été appliquées à des
entités financières, elles ont été elles
ont des individus à des individus, elles
ont été il y a eu la saisie des avoirs
russes dans un certain nombre
d'endroits. Euh ce qui pose un problème
parce que ça veut dire que les avoirs
d'autres pays se disent bah si nos
avoirs sont placés dans tel pays, et
bien à ce moment-là il risque de trésie
aussi. On les a on les a congelé et on
prend les intérêts pour aider. On prend
les intérêts. Exactement. Mais là, on
pense aller vendre là, ça pose problème
plutôt, non ? Ça pose problème. Les
enfin les sanctions, les sanctions,
c'est fait pour être détourné. Donc les
sanction sur l'énergie par exemple, on
voit très bien que la l'Inde, par
exemple, est importatrice de pétrole
russe. Elle le raffine, elle le revend
plus cher aux Européens. Bref, qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé ? Les sanctions
ont amené un certain nombre de pays à
sortir de la zone dollar et somme tout
ça est orchestré par la Chine qui elle
anticipe des sanctions futures. Et donc
les sanctions ont abouti aujourd'hui à
une économie double, une économie en
dollar d'un côté qui est celle de l'OCDE
et une économie qui est dans des
monnaies qui travaillent à coup de swap,
c'est-à-dire d'échange. Donc le rouble
contre le Yan chinois, contre la livre
turque parce qu'il faut quand même que
les touristes russes puissent continuer
à aller en Turquie sur les les les sur
les bords de de la Méditerranée
avec le Vietnam, avec l'Indonésie et
cetera. L'Égypte en livre en livre en
livre égyptienne. Ce qui est très
intéressant, c'est que la Chine est
aujourd'hui en train de prendre le
leadership d'un système qui est un
système
différent du système dollar. Et ça va de
paire avec chaque à quoi on assiste
lentement mais sûrement qui est la
ddolarisation. La plupart des pays du
monde sans pays dans le monde ont la
Chine comme premier partenaire
commercial. Ils n'ont pas envie de
renoncer à leur partenariat commercial
avec la Chine aux investissements
chinois. La Chine, elle a monté tout un
dispositif. Elle est leader au sein des
bricks. Les bricks, c'est Brésil,
Russie, Inde, Chine, Afrique du Sud,
plus quatre autres maintenant et 35 pays
qui attendent de rentrer. Leur objectif
c'est quoi ? C'est pas des moindres.
Comment pour les 45 qui attendent de
rentrer, c'est pas des moindres ? C'est
pas des moindres. Il y a des pays, il y
a des pays comme l'Indonésie, il y a des
pays comme des pays d'Amérique latine,
la Colombie par exemple, il y a des pays
d'Amérique d'Afrique du Nord, il y a des
pays d'Afrique. Bref, c'est c'est le
monde entier. Leur objectif n'est pas de
créer à terme peut-être une monnaie qui
ne serait pas le dollar. Leur objectif
c'est de refuser l'hégémonie du dollar
et les contreffets des sanctions. Parce
qu'à partir du moment où on est pris
comme nous l'avons été en Iran par
exemple, on se retire d'un accord. Trump
sort de l'accord nucléaire de l'Iran.
Nous nous retrouvons anglais, allemands
en particulier et nous-même nous nous
trouvons face à des Iraniens et je l'ai
vécu personnellement qui vous disent
"Ben, on a signé cet accord. Vous nous
avez promis 40 milliards
d'investissements en échange de la
limitation que nous nous sommes imposés
à notre souveraineté qui était celle
d'avoir l'arme nucléaire. Comment vous
allez faire ? Bon et alors on dit ben on
va pouvoir on va continuer à investir.
Et là les Américains nous disent "Ah ben
non, si vous investissez vous êtes privé
d'utilisation du dollar et vos
investissements aux États-Unis, vous
pouvez en faire votre deuil." Qu'est-ce
qu'on fait ? La plupart des pays et
notamment les pays émergents dont je
parlais tout à l'heure qui sont ces
puissances politiques, économiques,
technologiques et militaires ne veulent
pas en passer par là. Nous on fait quoi
nous ? C'est alors justement c'est eux
on fait un réflexe de Lawrence. C'est
eux qui constituent les bricks. Il
constituent les bricks et derrière les
Chinois ont monté les routes les routes
de la soie route de la soie fluviale,
route de la soie terrestre environ 150
pays qui ont des accords avec eux. Les
Chinois ont monté un dispositif
équivalent du Swift. Alors, c'est pas la
messagerie Swift, mais c'est une chambre
de compensation en y qui permet bah de
faire des échanges en y. Qui se sert de
ça ? Et bien des grands pays comme
l'Arabie Saoudite. Est-ce qu'on sait que
la 40 % du pétrole importé en Chine
vient d'Arabie Saoudite et qu'une partie
de ce pétrole est réglé en y ? Ce qui
veut dire que petit à petit, on a des y
qui s'imposent comme monnaie de
transaction. Le Yuan ne va pas être une
monnaie de réserve parce que ça voudrait
dire libérer le marché des libéraliser
le marché des capitaux. Et ça le les
Chinois ne l'accepteront jamais parce
qu'il y a une incertitude mais les
Chinois gèrent le Yan pas mal et donc on
a une monnaie de remplacement euh et
sans compter les systèmes de banque
centrale à banque centrale. Donc on a
une économie parallèle au dollar qui est
en train de se mettre en place et de
prendre de l'importance. Pour le moment,
on me dira "Ah oui, mais le dollar c'est
encore 60 % des transactions dans le
monde." Peut-être un peu plus
d'ailleurs. Non non, c'est 60 %, c'était
beaucoup plus il y a encore quelques
années. Le yan, c'est maintenant près de
10 % il y a une croissance
exponentielle. Donc c'est quelque chose
qu'il faut prendre en considération et
nos entreprises aujourd'hui et les
entreprises du monde entier notamment à
l'Ouest doivent prendre en considération
ce genre de chos parce que quand vous
avez un
fournisseur de premier rang qui est
chinois ou quand vous avez dans votre
chaîne d'approvisionnement des produits
chinois, comment vous allez payer le
chinois ? Donc vous êtes obligé d'avoir
deux comptabilités, une en dollar et une
en y pour pas vous faire prendre au
pattes si jamais vous êtes pris à
commercier avec la Chine car à
commercier avec la Chine car la Chine
anticipe des sanctions. elle commence à
venir sur les semi-conducteurs et
autres. Et dans la confrontation dont je
parlais tout à l'heure entre Chine et
États-Unis, on ne peut pas exclure qu'à
un moment quelconque, les Chinois se
verront imposer des sanctions par les
États-Unis et donc tous les pays qui
commerceront avec la Chine, qui
contribueront au développement de la
Chine ou sur certains produits seront
sanctionnés. Donc le monde est en train
de se fracturer et ça c'est une
dimension qu'il faut vraiment avoir en
tête qui fait partie du bouleversement
dans lequel les diplomatiees essayent de
se retrouver. On pousse l'expérience de
pensée.
La confrontation Chine-Amérique, tu me
disais les les sanctions, c'est pour
éviter de faire la guerre. Oui, c'est
parce que tu connais rien en guerre
économique.
Pourquoi ça ? Bah parce que les
sanctions, c'est un processus de guerre
économique. Oui. Tu connais le vieil
adage de la guerre économique ? Vas-y.
Un chômeur coûte plus cher qu'un mort.
Ça te fait marrer. Peut-être. Peut-être.
Mais en l'occurrence, en l'occurrence,
les sanctions ne fonctionnent pas bien.
Les sanctions affaiblissent. Elles ne
font que renforcer, je dirais, la la
cohésion d'un peuple autour de son
leader. En général, c'est le leader
qu'on veut sanctionner. Lui, ça ne le
touche en rien. Ça touche les
populations. Les populations sont
appauvrires, les populations sont mais
elles sont encore et les populations
sont encore plus vindicatives vis-à-vis
du de celui qui a imposé les sanctions.
Prends-toi à l'envers. On prend on prend
les choses à l'envers. Et donc alors je
ne dis pas qu'il ne faut pas appliquer
qu'il ne faut jamais appliquer de
sanction. Il peut y avoir des cas
particuliers où ça a fonctionné, mais
d'une manière générale les sanctions
systématiques comme on le fait et là je
vois qu'on va passer un 18e paquet de
sanctions sur l'énergie avec la Russie
mais la Russie va continuer à exporter
son énergie. La Russie a des pipelines
un peu partout. La Russie va continuer à
commercer. La Russie a à déplacer son
centre de gravité de l'Europe vers
l'Asie. Prenons-le en prenons-le en
considération. C'est une réalité. La
Russie d'ailleurs n'est pas isolée.
Regardons le sommet de Casan l'année
dernière. Arrêtons de nous bercer de
fausses idées. La Russie reste forte. Au
sommet de 15 ans, 35 chefs d'état
étaient présents. Elle est où notre
conduite introspective de nos élites ?
Je crois que nous nous laissons aveuglés
par une idéologie. La guerre en Ukraine
effectivement a été déclenchée par une
agression qui constitue une violation du
droit international. Elle a abouti
effectivement à à des annexions de
territoires qui sont une autre violation
du droit international. Mais tout ça, ça
se règle autour d'une table de
négociation à condition d'être soi-même
assez fort pour pouvoir être en face de
l'interlocuteur. Il faut le faire avec
les Américains. Les Américains ont
envisagé d'une autre manière de régler
le sujet. On le règle par le commerce.
Regardons la façon dont se passe les
choses aujourd'hui. La négociation
américaine au-russe. Très intéressant.
Première réunion 14 février à Riad. Le
jour de la Saint-Valentin. Le jour de la
Saint-Valentin. Qui était présent ?
D'abord, on a dit il y a pas les
Ukrainiens. Les Ukrainiens ne pouvaient
pas être présents. C'était d'abord une
normalisation entre la Russie et les
États-Unis. On seul on se reparlait pour
la première fois depuis des années. Qu'
y avait-il ? Il y avait des ministres,
les deux ministres Rubio, Lavrof et puis
une délégation avec des gens
qui ne sont pas toujours là et notamment
un certain Kiril Dimitriev qui est le
président du fond souverain russe. Donc
derrière cette négociation, il y a du
business. Il y a du business parce que
dans l'idée de Trump tout est business,
tout est deal. Le deal, c'est quoi ? Le
deal, c'est intimider l'adversaire,
c'est le déstabiliser, c'est créer
l'incertitude, mais c'est créer un moyen
de récupérer des avantages économiques
pour son compte. Derrière cette
négociation, il y avait aussi dans cette
délégation à Ariade, il y avait
quelqu'un qui s'occupe de de l'Arctique.
Pourquoi ? parce qu'il y a du gaz
naturel liquéfié dans l'Actic et qu'il y
a des gros investissements à faire et
que ces investissements, ils doivent
être faits. Les Américains
souhaiteraient qu'il soient les les les
Russes souhaitaient qu'il soit fait avec
les Chinois. Les Chinois n'ont pas voulu
entrer dans cette dans cette négociation
et faire cet investissement parce que
ils avaient peur de d'être sanctionnés
précisément en travaillant avec les
Russes. Donc aujourd'hui, c'est un
accord russo-américain qui va sans doute
exploiter le gaz naturel liquéfié qui
est dans l'Arctique. L'Europe
nous l'Europe on pas on n'est pas là.
L'Europe on n'est pas là l'Europe. On
revient à un autre au sujet que je
disais tout à l'heure, on ne construit
pas l'Europe contre la Russie. Qu'est-ce
qu'on fait dans ce contexte ? On
renforce nos moyens, on renforce nos
moyens militaires, ça c'est très bien,
mais est-ce qu'on est prêt à négocier
pied à pied des accords de sécurité sur
l'Ukraine ? Négocier avec les Russes, je
dirais un modus viv, réfléchir à ce que
Macron avait proposé il y a quelques
années qui était une architecture
européenne de sécurité incluant la
Russie. La sécurité, je reviens à ce que
j'ai dit tout à l'heure, c'est un point,
c'est quelque chose de fondamental pour
un individu mais pour un pays également.
La sécurité est quelque chose
d'indivisible. ta sécurité et ma
sécurité. Mais entendons-nous sur ce
qu'on met en face de l'autre, l'un en
face de l'autre et entendons-nous sur la
manière dont on se contrôle. Ça
s'appelle les mesures de confiance. Tu
vas déployer tel type d'armement, je
veux le savoir. Je vais déployer tel
type, je vais te le faire savoir. Et
cetera et cetera. Et donc ça c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut construire tard
faire ça. Comment c'est pas trop tard ?
C'est jamais trop tard. C'est jamais
trop tard. Il est toujours temps de le
faire et un jour, il faudra le faire. De
toute façon, on sait tous, passe-moi
l'expression, mais les Russes nous ont
chié dans les bottes. Oui, on a chié
dans les bottes des Russes. On a des
diplomates qui sont
non chalants ou dans une autre idéologie
ou avec une mauvaise information ou une
mauvaise prospective où ils vivent dans
un film avec des louinettes roses où ils
prennent de la drogue, des champignons.
C'est pas trop tard ça quand on met ce
climat de
ressources naturelles Oui. d'accession
aux ressources naturelles, d'une
économie sur une fonction exponentielle,
d'un dollar qui va des bricks qui sont
assis sur un trésor de matière première
et nous les Européens censés être la
troisème voie, l'Europe de la paix,
l'Europe des machins,
on pousse à l'armement, on n'est pas en
train, ils ne comprennent pas que ça va
tourner vinaigre,
on leur parle plus, on a plus de sources
d'information de première main qui
capable d'aller discuter avec eux, faire
passer des idées, que ces idées soient
respectées parce que il y a une relation
de confiance,
l'Europe est en train de se faire
dépesser
et on a des politiciens qui ne savent
pas comment les œufs sont arrivés dans
la boîte. Ils pensent que les poules,
elles pont des boîtes de 6. Comment on
fait avec ça ? On voit l'augmentation
des partis extrémistes un peu partout en
Europe. Ouais, bien sûr. On voit les
parties censées être modérés dire "Ah
ben je ne comprends pas, c'est euh les
Russes, les Chinois qui doivent pousser
des ingérences étrangères, supposé pas
supposé, j'en passé des meilleurs ou à
la à la marge du trait."
Et nous, on se dit "Oh là là là là, il
faut se réarmer, on n pas d'énergie, on
a une monnaie fantôme, on n pas foutu de
ce [__] d'accord entre le sud et le
nord de l'Europe,
on passe pour des clown. Non mais à
défaut de passer pour des clownes, le
tableau que tu fais est un tableau qui
est assez juste. Mais est-ce que il faut
se contenter de tableau que tu as fait
ma ma conviction et que il est toujours
temps, je dirais
avec les qualités de chacun et si
possible de manière collective de
remonter au créneau. Je te parle de
sécurité. Qui parle aujourd'hui de
sécurité en Europe ? Qui parle de la
paix en Europe ? Qu'est-ce qui encore
crédible en Europe ?
C'est tout le problème. C'est tout le
problème. Qui aujourd'hui est prêt à
parler de la paix ? Moi ce qui me
fascine c'est que Trump
ébranle je dirais fait un rebat les
cartes dans tous les domaines. Bon on
aime on aime pas il s'agit pas d'aimer
ou de ne pas aimer. Il rebat les cartes.
Il rebat notamment une carte qui était
cette relation entre la Russie et les
États-Unis qui est une relation en chien
de faillance depuis la fin de l'Union
soviétique.
Et cette idée américaine que la guerre
froide s'est poursuivie.
Bon, nous nous avons essayé en Europe de
créer des coopérations avec les Russes.
Elles n'ont pas abouti et puis on a la
guerre à nos portes. Au moment où les
Américains décident que la guerre froide
finalement on pourrait y mettre fin,
c'est nous qui décidons
de maintenir l'esprit de la guerre
froide,
du moins nous en donnons l'impression.
Tu as pas l'impression. Alors même que
au moment où Trump parle au Russes, il
serait important que nous nous disions
aujourd'hui souffle un vent nouveau. Ce
vent nouveau est un vent qui peut
apporter la fin de ce conflit meurtrier
entre deux pays. Mais ça nécessite un
certain nombre de conditions avant
d'être finie. les garanties de sécurité
pour l'Ukraine, une négociation euh bon
de redéploiement des troupes et cetera,
enfin bref, des tas de conditions qu'on
examine. Allons en parler avec les
Russes. Est-ce que ce que les Russes
essayent d'imposer avec ce mémorandum
déposé le 2 juin qui sont en fait leurs
conditions les mêmes et quelque chose
que nous devons ignorer, que nous devons
laisser uniquement aux Américains. Il
est bon que nous avons une diplomatie,
nous avons des moyens de nous exprimer,
nous avons nous sommes une puissance
nucléaire, nous la France, nous avons je
le répète, des responsabilité au titre
du Conseil de sécurité. Et donc pourquoi
est-ce que nous n'allons pas avec les
Allemands, s'ils le veulent, avec les
Polonais, ça sera plus compliqué.
L'Europe est divisée, tu l'as dit.
Pourquoi Boris Johnson, il a motivé les
Ukrainiens à éviter de signer des
papiers ? Parce que je pense qu'il
suivait un plan qui était un plan de
d'affaiblir la Russie. Je pense qu'il y
a chez les Britanniques depuis toujours
l'idée du fameux big game qui était
depuis 1856, depuis la guerre de Crimé,
il faut affaiblir l'Empire russe.
L'Empire russe menace les Indes et donc
les dans le schéma dans le schéma de
mémoire collective des Britanniques, il
y a une incapacité à travailler avec les
Russes. Ce n'est pas le cas de la
France. La France est dans un une autre
tradition historique, même si la
relation avec la Russie et même Car
d'encos l'a très bien écrit dans un
livre sur de Pierre Land à à Lenin
l'histoire de la France et de la Russie,
c'est une histoire d'occasion manquée.
Euh quand Pierre Le Grand vient à la
cour de Versailles, on le traite comme
s'il n'existait pas. Euh quand le
marquis de Custine est ambassadeur, il
décrit la Russie d'une manière
effroyable. Bref, on a manqué des
occasions, mais regardons la politique
que nous avons mené à la fin du 19e
siècle dans l'alliance franco-russe.
Regardons le rôle joué par les divisions
russes sur la Marne en 1914. Regardons
le général de Gaulle, comment ?
Normandie. Normandie Yémen Normandie
Yéen. C'est quand même audacieux
d'envoyer des des des aviateurs de la
France libre. J'ai eu la chance de
connaître Roland La Poape qui était un
homme incroyable, fondateur de de de
Marine Lande à Antibe, enfin un génie
euh le type héros l'Union soviétique euh
à 22 ans euh avec ses camarades, un
camarade qui a préféré se tuer pour que
son que le dans un autre avion un des
avions de l'escadré Normandin Yémémen
pour que le le mécanicien russe puisse
survivre des des actes héroïques qui ont
marqué la relation. Qu'est-ce que fait
le général de Gaul en 1944 ? Le premier
déplacement qu'il fait, il va en Russie,
il va Je regardais une une
vidéo dans laquelle on voit le le le
général de Gaulle accueillir le
président Kossigin.
Mais c'est un discours de respect, on se
parle, nous on n'est pas amis. Le bloc
soviétique pesait de tout son poids et
il avait en France le relais du parti
communiste qui obtenait des dizaines de
pourc voix à chaque élection. Mais
néanmoins, on vivait, je dirais dans
dans une espèce de paix armée. Est-ce
qu'on ne peut pas aujourd'hui revenir
vers cette détente d'une manière ou
d'une autre ? Encore faut-il se parler
là, le refus de se parler, le désir
d'aller jusqu'au bout d'un conflit dont
on ne sait pas où il va aller. Quelle
est la solution politique que nous
proposons ? Aucune. Alors oui, peut-être
il y aura un conflit gelé à nos portes.
Il y a Mais quels sont nos projets ? Je
n'en sais rien. Et ça c'est quand un
vrai sujet. Mais la guerre ne peut pas
continuer indéfiniment parce que les
Russes avancent pendant ce temps-là et
plus les Russes avancent, plus la
posture qui sera la nôtre dans une
future négociation qui arrivera un jour
sera défavorable. Plus ils avancent,
plus ils perdent des gens, plus ils se
radicalisent. Mais ils ont ils ont des
ressources.
Ils ont des ressources.
Ils perdent des gens, les Ukrainiens en
perdent aussi. Et en plus de ça, alors
si on veut parler moral, nous continuons
à pousser cette guerre en Ukraine
dans laquelle nous ne mettrons jamais le
pied nous-même. Donc nous n'aurons pas
un soldat français tué dans la guerre en
Ukraine. Par contre, les soldats
ukrainiens peuvent continuer à y aller
parce qu'on va continuer à leur
promettre d'envoyer des armes et autres.
Ils se battent pour nos résult ils se
battent pour nos valeurs.
C'est une les Ukrainiens,
la démocratie ukrainienne est sans doute
Oui, il y a plus de démocratie en
Ukraine qu'il n'y a qu'il n'y en a en
Russie. Sans doute. Ce n'est pas un
parangon de la démocratie. C'est un long
chemin. C'est un pays qui dans les
classements je dirais sur la corruption
et autres n'est pas un exemple. C'est un
pays qui a droit à vivre dans ses
frontières. qui a droit à vivre qui a
droit à vivre dans des frontières
inviolables, qui a droit à l'intégrité
de son territoire, qui a droit à sa
souveraineté. Elle est reconnue, mettre
des des bases américaines chez elle,
mais qu'on ne nous raconte pas que tout
ça, je dirais euh est totalement
innocent. Ce ne sont pas euh je je ne
vais pas Ce qui s'est passé s'est passé.
Il y a-t-il eu des bases américaines ?
Il y a-t un ? Sans doute que oui.
Aujourd'hui, la situation est une
situation dans laquelle les Russes
Washington Post toi, les Russes
avancent,
les Ukrainiens sont en position de
faiblesse, nous leur faisons des
promesses que nous aurons du mal à
tenir. Nous n'enverrons pas nos propres
troupes parce qu'ils ne voulons pas nous
ne voulons pas de cobigérance à leur
côté sur le territoire. Je pense qu'à un
moment, il faut arrêter la guerre d'une
manière ou d'une autre et il faut pour
cela parler à la puissance opposée. Il
faut peut-être changer nos
chancelleries.
Euh euh pourquoi comment tu pourrais
m'expliquer que Poutine il a pas fait la
guerre en Ukraine comme je dirais à
l'américaine ? Pourquoi Poutine il a pas
fait la guerre à l'américaine ? C'estàd
aplatir tout le pays et ensuite envoyer
les GI parce que je suis pas sûr qu'il
en avait les moyens d'aplatir tout le
pays. Je suis pas sûr.
C'est ta première lecture ? C'est ta
seule lecture ? Je pense que les Russes
n'avancent pas aussi facilement en
Ukraine qu'il l'aurait imaginé.
D'ailleurs, on voit les les combats
qu'ils ont mené à Bachmout pour prendre
le nœud ferroviaire de Bmout. Arkerson,
Zaporija qui n'est pas stabilisé.
Oui, ils avancent mais village par
village. Alors, est-ce que les Russes
pourraient faire des bombardements
massifs faire un le carpet de bombing
comme ils l'ont fait en en Syrie ? C'est
très difficile parce qu'il comme Israël
a fait à Gaza ou comme Israël fait à
Gaza. Voilà. Bon, d'autres le font
ailleurs. Euh, toujours moins de 3 m de
haut. Tu sais pourquoi ?
Tu sais pourquoi ? Pourquoi ? Parce que
quand ça fait plus de 3 m de haut, tu
peux mettre des snipers et c'est encore
plus chiant à prendre. C'est encore plus
compliqué. Oui, c'est encore plus
compliqué. Mais en l'occurrence, les
Russes n'avancent pas aussi pour les
civils. Les Russes ont le temps le droit
international aussi.
Les Russes ont le temps pour eux. Ils
ont la ressource humaine, ils ont la
ressource industrielle
et donc ils avancent.
Soyons réalistes, regardons la réalité
des Russes qui avancent. Et en même
temps que nous, je le répète, en même
temps que nous essayons d'être plus fort
dans une négociation qui viendra bien un
jour, réfléchissons
à ne pas engager cette négociation dans
une situation qui sera désespérée.
Pourquoi il a pas parce que bon, dans
son arsenal, il doit avoir un peu du
sale. Pourquoi il a pas un antif
avec 3 qu avion ? On coupe la tête tout
de suite.
Pourquoi il a pas fait ça ? parce que je
suis parce que je ne suis pas sûr qu'il
aurait pu le faire. Je pense qu'il y
aurait un petit orelchic au lieu d'avoir
une frapinette. Ah, il pourrait tirer un
orchnik, il pourrait mais à ce moment-là
là on entre dans un rapport de Je vais
répondre à la question que je te posais.
Tu sais pourquoi ils ont pas écrasé
l'Ukraine ? Ils l'ont ils en ont pas
fait genre un Pourquoi ? Parce que les
Russes et les Ukrains, il y a des
Ukrainiens qui ont de la famille en
Russie. Bah oui, ça bien sûr. Et ils ont
des Russes qui ont aussi de la famille
en Ukraine.
Si tu massacres le pays, que tu écrases
tout le monde, c'est un truc qui
s'appelle l'arithmétique de la
rébellion.
C'est-à-dire que la famille ukrainienne
qui a de la famille en Russie, ils vont
s'appeler, ils vont dire Poutine c'est
un gros sing.
terrorisme en Russie, changement de
régime. Donc je pense qu'il a pas écrasé
l'Ukraine
en mode très très sale de peur de se
faire déstabiliser chez lui. Ça c'est
une hypothèse intéressante que je n'ai
jamais vu mais qui effectivement on sait
qu'il y a en gros logique qui est
logique. On a entre 10 et 15 % de Russes
qui sont mariés des Ukrainiens et
réciproquement depuis des années. Et
depuis depuis des années, le nombre de
Russes qu'on voit qui ont un grand-père
ukrainien, seul génit lui-même et de la
famille ukrainienne, enfin les les tous
les grands russes ont des Ukrainiens
dans leur famille et tous les tous les
héros tous les grands Ukrainiens ont ont
du Russes dans la famille. Exactement.
Et et tous les tous les soviétiques
avaient étaient à la fois ukrainien et
russes d'une manière ou d'une autre.
Donc ça c'est une hypothèse que que je
n'avais que j'ai jamais vu évoquer mais
qui est qui est intéressante
effectivement c'est très possible.
Est-ce que tu as un autre pays euh tu tu
souhaiterais qu'on regarde plus en
détail un autre continent ? Toutes
sortes de continents. L'Afrique Macron,
il a fait du bon travail en Afrique, non
? Il a fait changer des climatisations,
il a il a fait des blagues pourries, il
a été boire des bières.
L'Afrique, je crois que c'est un
problème très très profond. Non, mais
Macron, c'est aussi un problème très
profond, non ? Oui, mais ça bon d'autres
beaucoup de gens le disent effectivement
c'est surtout les africains non sont
peut-être un peu énervés par les Russes
et les Chinois derrière. Je sais pas
s'ils ont encore mesuré ce que les
Russes et les Chinois représentent chez
eux. Ce qui est sûr, c'est que les
Chinois payent et construisent. Et les
Russes pour le moment, bon, j'ai vu que
Wagner se retirait de se retirait de du
Mali. On verra la suite. Moi ce que
j'essaie de savoir c'est pourquoi ça n'a
pas marché pour nous.
Je pense qu'il y a plusieurs raisons. Je
vais te donner un exemple. Oui. Alors,
l'Égypte a ses diplay et nous on a
Vas-y. Non. Bon, vas-y, continue. Non,
j'essaie de voir pourquoi on a perdu on
a perdu l'Afrique occidentale parce
qu'on n pas en Afrique, on est encore en
Afrique. On est très présent en Angola,
on est présent au Mozambique, on est
présent en Afrique du Sud, on est
présent au Nigéria. Je ne parle pas de
l'Afrique au nord, l'Afrique du Nord, je
parle de l'Afrique au Sud du Sahara. Là
où nous ne sommes plus, c'est dans
l'Afrique où traditionnellement on était
très présent.
On y a on a retiré tous nos capitaux.
Euh Boloré a retiré avait les ports. On
a même plus les ports. La France s'est
désengagée de l'Afrique depuis
longtemps. La France s'est désengagée de
l'Afrique en terme de moyens.
J'ai un camarade qui a été qui avait
commencé sa carrière comme conseiller de
coopération en Centrafrique. Nous avions
des centaines de coopérants. Quand il se
passait quelque chose, on le savait. on
pouvait répondre à la demande. Il s'est
retrouvé ensuite au Sénégal comme
ambassadeur et là il ne savait
absolument ce qui se passait à
Saint-Louis. Il savait pas ce qui se
passait à Ziginchor et ça c'était un
vrai problème.
Donc
l'attrition des moyens est quelque chose
qui nous a fait perdre énormément. et
qui dit attitiontition des moyens dit
qu'on perd et on revient à ce que tu
disais sur les limers des gens qui
écoutent ce qui se passe. On a perdu le
contact avec les populations. Nous
sommes restés dans ces pays avec des
bases militaires, même si Sarkozy avait
revu tout le dispositif qui ont été
accusés de complicité de soutien à des
régimes onis par les populations. Et les
jeunes générations, c'est ell qu'on a
perdu parce que les jeunes générations
extrêmement nombreuses sont dans une
recherche d'identité où il est facile de
leur dire tout ça c'est la faute des
Français.
Mais nous on est là, on leur parle.
Voilà et donc encore une relation de
confiance et donc on a perdu. Donc alors
en plus de ça la relation par
l'attrition des moyens a été très
militarisée. On a gardé des bases, on a
gardé des militaires, on a gardé mais
pourquoi faire ? On a eu ces opérations
Barcane, Serval et enfin Serval et
Barcane qui nous a coûté énormément, qui
nous a coûté en homme, qui nous a coûté
en blessé, qui nous a coûté en énergie,
en matériel, en argent, tout ce qu'on
peut imaginer. Quand on regarde le
résultat, c'est dramatique. C'est
dramatique.
C'est ce ce départ, le départ du Nigère
s'est passé dans des conditions
absolument incroyables. Alors moi, je
connais pas assez bien la situation
africaine pour en faire une analyse
détaillée, mais je pense qu'on a perdu
les populations, on a perdu la jeunesse
et on l'a perdu par attrition des moyens
et par, je dirais, une une trop grande
implication militaire. Alors que c'est
par la coopération, par la présence
qu'on devait faire les choses. Donc
voilà. Donc un jour ça reviendra. Mais
pour le moment je crois que c'est
limier. Bon le limier en général il est
con. Non non le limier est pas con. Ah
le limier c'est un limier donc il est il
est il est bien dressé le limier
surtout. Il est bien éduqué. Il est bien
éduqué. Bon au bout de la laisse celui
qui donne le cap. Oui.
Ah bah c'est tout. On revient à ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure. Il faut que il
faut que celui qui qui tient la laisse
où va la France sache où il va Maurice
dans dans l'état actuel des choses h
avec les bout de laisse à gauche
des des fins limés sur trois pattes
borgnes sour
avec des copains européens qui qui ont
une vieille idéologie
de de
démocrates
arriéré
en Europe. essayant de faire perdurer
l'idéologie de la guerre froide. Nous,
la France, on fait quoi ?
La France
a perdu la singularité
de ce qu'elle était. La France était un
pays singulier qui n'appartenait à
personne. La France est entrée, je
dirais, dans s'est mis dans le lignage
ou dans la dans le sillage d'un grand
pays qui s'appelle les États-Unis qui
s'est imposé à elle petit à petit. La
France a perdu l'originalité des
contacts qu'elle entretenait. La France
n'a pas su capitaliser sur ce qu'elle a
de précieux qui est son capital
politique, son cap, c'est-à-dire
l'héritage des lumières, son capital
civilisationnel,
son capital culturel.
Je quand j'étais euh en poste comme
ambassadeur euh je me rendais compte
qu'il y a une attente de France encore
aujourd'hui. C'est extraordinaire. Que
dit la France ? On ent quelque part. Ah
les Français, qu'est-ce que vous avez à
dire ? Malheureusement, on a souvent pas
grand-chose à dire, de moins en moins à
dire. Et pourtant, quand on fait des
expositions, quand on fait du spectacle
vivant, quand on fait une
représentation, quand on se met en
scène, quand la France se met en scène,
les gens suivent la France. On a souvent
montré un cap. On a souvent montré un
cap depuis et le général de Gaulle, on
revient souvent à De Gaulle, mais De
Gaulle a réussi à à faire un un
empactage de tout ce que la France
pouvait porter comme valeur.
Aujourd'hui, tout ça a été perdu de vue.
Alors, par manque d'éducation, par
manque de suivi, par manque de
continuité, par facilité.
Nous avons lâché des technologies
industrielles
avec une légèreté incroyable. Je pense
que Alstom mais Alstom et bien d'autres
et bien d'autres quand je vois Technipp,
quand je vois les cimenteries, quand je
vois tout ce que nous avons perdu nous
avions à une époque nous avions nos
grandes entreprises, nos grands
retailers donc sur tous les continents,
nous avons vendu Nous avons vendu au fur
et à mesure par faiblesse du capitalisme
français par apa du gain par apa du gain
par apa du gain je pense que l'ultra par
forfure l'ultralibéralisme par forfure
par forfaiture aussi peut-être l'ult
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire fortfaiture
pour les jeunes qui n'ont que 400 mots
de voculaire ? Mensonge, c'est un
mensonge. Abandon de poste. C'est
abandon de poste, c'est une c'est un
parjure, c'est un mensonge. Euh nous et
c'est une dissimulation aussi la
forfaiture. Euh je pense que
l'ultralibéralisme ne nous a pas réussi.
Il nous a dépouillé.
Et moi, je suis surpris. J'ai vécu la
crise de 2008 en Angleterre. J'étais
ambassadeur à Londres. Euh et donc c'est
c'était
il y a eu des signes prémonitoires, il y
avait une arrogance de ce monde de la
finance par rapport à un pays comme la
France. Et puis un jour je me retrouve
avec un type de Lman Brothers c'était 3
jours avant l'effondrement. Je dis c'est
compliqué, il y a une il y a un
rationnement des liquidités depuis le
mois d'août. Donc tout le monde se
rendait compte que ça allait chauffer.
Et donc après il y a eu un grand espoir
et et Sarkozy qu'on aime ou qu'on a'ime
pas mais Sarkozy a eu la vista qui a
consisté à réunir tous les Européens
plus les britanniques et les Américains.
Et c'était Bush le dernier mandat de
Bush derniers mois de son mandat. Et on
s'est ressisi et le système financier
interial ne s'est pas effondré mais il
ne s'est pas réformé pour autant. Oui,
on a on a on a des fonds de stabilité
qu'on a créé ici et là, mais par
exemple, je vois euh les la banque de
détails et la banque d'affaires qui sont
restés fusionnées. Je vois la façon dont
on a on a on a floué un certain nombre
de petits. Je vois Ryan BK of Scotland.
Euh il y a des des centaines de milliers
de personnes qui ont été mises sur la
paille. Est-ce que les dirigeants ont
été punis d'une manière ou d'une autre ?
Rien du tout. Il y a eu aucune sanction.
Et donc on a continué comme et la France
s'en est pas si mal tirée. On a des
grandes banques françaises. Quand je
vois BNP Pariba, c'est une grande
banque. BNP Pariba est une grande banque
de la planète. Celle qui a pris des
sanctions américaines. Celle qui a pris
des sanctions américaines. Euh mais si
on regarde à l'échelle européenne, BNP
Pariba fait que la France existe sur le
plan financier. Un regard sur la
Bundesbank.
Bah la Bundesban, la Bundesbank elle
fait partie elle est elle existe comme
existe la Banque de France mais elle est
elle est intégré dans la Banque centrale
européenne. Tu me fais parler tu veux
parler de la Deutsche Banque ? Merci. La
Deutsche Ban. Ah ben la Deutsche Ban
c'est une elle est très stable. C'est
une banque sereine une banque d'affaires
avec des des reins des reins solides.
Objectivement il y a presque plus de
système financier allemand. Les
Allemands sont dans et c'est un grand
sujet pour aujourd'hui. Pourquoi ?
La banque, la Commerce Banque et la
Deutsche Ban étaient les banques
allemandes. Les banques allemandes,
banques d'affaires pour la plupart.
Elles ont vécu sous perfusion et la
Commerce Banque est encore sous
perfusion.
Derrière la commerce banque, il y a
aujourd'hui une tentative de reprise par
une banque italienne. Les Allemands,
pour des raisons nationales, s'y
opposent farouchement.
Le problème c'est que derrière ça, il
est important pour nous dans la
configuration générale du monde avec les
États-Unis d'un côté, la Chine de
l'autre, de créer un marché financier
européen suffisamment profond comme on
dit pour pouvoir pour que les gens ils
placent leur argent et ils fassent des
investissements. Aujourd'hui, 2 à 300
milliards d'euros vont se placer aux
États-Unis. Alors, est-ce que ça va
durer avec la situation actuelle ? sans
doute moins que c'était le cas avant,
mais du temps de Biden, c'est ce qui
s'est passé jusqu'à la fin parce que il
y a un marché américain qui est un
marché intéressant. Il n'y a pas de
marché financier européen. Il y a 27
petits marchés avec 27 signatures
différentes. Ce qui nous empêche de
faire les grands investissements
recommandés dans le rapport Dragiy par
exemple sur les hautes technologies où
nous on est en train de prendre un
retard gigantesque qui nous amènera à
adopter les hautes technologies
américaines ou les hautes technologies
chinoises. On en est là. Ça c'est un
vrai sujet. Les Allemands aujourd'hui,
ils ont un système à part avec un
système lié au fonctionnement des
lenders avec les caisses d'épargne
locales. Je les ai fréquenté moi tous
ces gens, ce sont les rois du les rois
du pétrole, les les présidents de Caisse
d'Épargne, les Landes Bank qui sont les
banques des États fédérés de l'Allemagne
euh qui sont en général pas très bien
portantes. On a un vrai problème
financier. Il fait ce problème financier
fait partie des problèmes à résoudre
aujourd'hui sur lesquels nous devrions
être plus énergiques. Tous les Français,
nous avons des choses à dire et
malheureusement
tant que nous n'aurons pas
une union bancaire en Europe, et bien
nous serons faibles dans le le partage
du monde tel qu'il est en train de se
dessiner aujourd'hui avec Trump. Et nous
n'avons pas tiré les leçons de la crise
de 2008. Maurice, est-ce que tu as trois
bouquins à conseiller à la communauté ?
Alors euh je conseillerai euh j'en ai
parlé tout à l'heure euh les mémoires du
prince de ligne parce qu'il faut lire ça
c'est le 18e siècle, c'est toujours très
intéressant. J'ai un autre livre qui
s'appelle de de
Staline à Hitler, d'un diplomate qui
s'appelait Robert Couondre qui était
ambassadeur à Berlin juste avant la
guerre de 3940 qui fait une analyse
extrêmement précise de la manière dont
s'est passé la conférence de Munique. On
en parle en permanence, c'est Munique
parci, Munique par là. C'est extrêmement
important de le lire. Et puis euh
je recommanderais de lire tout ce qui
peut être
autobiographie. J'ai pas
d'autobiographie particulière à
recommander, mais lire des
autobiographies ou des portraits, euh je
crois que c'est nécessaire. Et enfin, un
4è livre
que Bruno Lem et pas Bruno Lemire. Si je
devais, on me disait prends un livre qui
est un témoignage de ce qu'est l'Europe
et de ce qui reste encore de l'Europe
parce que nous l'avons en nous. C'est le
monde d'hier de Stéphan Sweig qui reste
pour moi le sommum de ce qu'est ce
patrimoine culturel européen dont nous
vivons encore et que nous respirons
chaque jour. Bon, est-ce que tu as un
conseil pour les jeunes générations ?
une bouteille à la mer, quelque chose
d'impérissable qui restera sur
l'internet avant que les Américains nous
retirent YouTube, Google, Microsoft et
que nos administrations se retrouvent le
bec dans l'eau. Je donnerai le conseil
que je donne à chaque fois que je suis
interrogé à la fin d'une conférence dans
une université ou ailleurs. Sortez de
votre zone de confort. N'allez ni à
Londres ni aux États-Unis. Vous serez
toujours rattrapé par ces ces ces zonesl
où ça se passe. Allez en Asie, allez
faire votre master de à Singapour, en
Australie, en Indonésie. en Inde, aller
en Afrique, éviter Pyong jusqu'à
maintenant, évitez Pyong mais allez en
Corée du Sud. Sortez de votre zone de
confort, c'est fondamental et on vous en
saura gré toute votre vie et vous-même
vous en sergé. Maurice, merci. Merci
beaucoup.
[Musique]